[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans les
matins du sénat un très beau texte un
texte ambitieux pour la sécurité sociale
voilà comment olivier veyrat a qualifié
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2021 aujourd'hui
c'est pierre moscovici qui est entendu
le président de la cour des comptes va
livrer son avis sur ce texte très
attendu en cette période de crise
sanitaire on regarde d'audition on en
reparle juste après époux distance entre
l'exécutif et le parlement
donc je voulais vous dire que vous
pourrez toujours compter sur le soutien
et sur la disponibilité de notre
institution
l'audition d'aujourd'hui m'offre
d'ailleurs l'occasion d'illustrer notre
mission d'assistance au parlement
puisque le rapport sur l'application des
lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale le ral c'était débit dans ce
cadre comme le rapport sur les j'ai
acheté est établi à la demande de votre
commission est en effet ma présentation
sera complétée par celle de la
communication relative au groupement
hospitalier de territoire je laisserai
le président de la 6ème chambre denis
morin vous en exposer le contenu aux
côtés de noël diricq président de
section de nicolas par next rapporteur
qui ont rassuré l'instruction et que je
veux remercier je suis également
accompagné vous l'avez dit de michèle
pappalardo
la rapporteur général de la cour de
stéphane seuil et conseillers m le
rapporteur général du rapport sur la
sécurité sociale d'antoine imberty
auditeurs leur apportant général adjoint
en effet vous avez devant vous des des
rapports et notamment un rapport très
volumineux
c'est pas toujours lié voulu me
travaillé m'enfin ça indique quand même
la mobilisation qui était la nôtre sur
ce sujet qui est la nôtre
chaque année il va rapporteurs ont
contribué à la rédaction du râle c'est
ses dires le grand sérieux que nous
abordons que nous apportons à cet
exercice est un travail qui mobilise en
fait presque la totalité de la sixième
chambre de la cour et il faut noter
qu'il a été cette année réalisée dans un
contexte exceptionnel vous le mentionnez
mal présidente celui la crise sanitaire
sans précédent que nous traversons
depuis mars
je précise toutefois que le rapport
n'aborde pas la gestion de la crise en
elle même dacourt aura bien sûr
l'occasion d'y revenir et intervenir
devant vous si vous le souhaitez nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans un contexte
économique particulièrement difficile
dans lequel nos transferts sociaux il
faut le souligner ont joué et continuent
à jouer un rôle essentiel pour amortir
en quelque sorte les conséquences de
cette crise pour nos concitoyens
notamment en comparaison d'autres pays
il ya bien un modèle social français et
une protection sociale qui occupe une
place essentielle dans notre pacte
républicain dont la cour à sa place est
une institution qui en est une des
quarante la situation actuelle était
exceptionnelle l'impact de la crise sur
la trajectoire la sécurité sociale est
tout à fait considérable
vous le voyez sur le slide comme on dit
qui apparaît puisque en effet en 2020 le
des équipes des comptes sociaux
atteindra des niveaux historiques avec
un déficit du régime général du fonds de
solidarité vieillesse qui s'élève à 44 4
millions de milliards d'euros pour vous
donner un point de comparaison c'était
28 milliards d'euros en 2010 à la suite
de crises financières nous pouvons donc
dire que la crise de lakovic 19 and
impact économique et financier supérieur
à celui de la crise de 2008 2014
cette situation conduit l'été dernier à
une nouvelle reprise de la dette par la
caisse d'amortissement de la dette
sociale la fameuse cadets ce reprises
elle aussi inédite par son montant
puisqu'elle s'élève à 136 milliards
d'euros et qu'elle a pour effet de
prolonger l'existence de la kadey ce
jusqu'en 2033
donc nous sommes face à un exercice qui
est hors norme pour nos comptes sociaux
et notre rapport cette année porte un
message simple clair qui est le suivant
nous voulons sauvegarder notre système
de sécurité sociale
c'est un maillon essentiel de cohésion
de solidarité dans notre pays
mais puisque nous pouvons alors nous
devons reconstruire progressivement une
nouvelle trajectoire de retour à
l'équilibré des comptes sociaux
la sécurité sociale ne peut pas être
durablement financées par l'emprunt
sauf à pénaliser définitivement les
générations futures ce message de la
déclinaison logique dans le domaine de
la sécurité sociale je suis dit que nous
devons porter en juin dernier dans notre
rapport sur la situation et les
perspectives des finances publiques
présentée devant vos collègues de la
commission des finances est aussi de la
position du haut conseil des finances
publiques que je le précise également
dans son dernier avis la soutenabilité
de la dette publique qui comprend bien
sûr la dette sociale et pour nous pour
la france pour nos concitoyens un enjeu
tout à fait central je vais revenir sur
ces éléments dans la première partie de
ma présentation pour atteindre ces
objectifs et ce sera la deuxième partie
de mon propos le contexte actuel de nos
finances publiques nous laisse pas
d'autre choix que d'agir sur la qualité
et sur la sélectivité de la dépense
sociale et la cour formule en ce sens
trois recommandations d'abord agir sur
les ressorts structurelle de la dépense
de sécurité sociale notamment du chemin
assurance maladie sans réduire bien sûr
la qualité de la prise en charge des
patients ensuite porté une attention
plus grande roue au public défavorisé en
ciblant mieux certaines prestations de
solidarité et en prévenant les impacts
sur ces publics des mesures générales de
maîtrise de dépenses
enfin il s'agit de poursuivre les
efforts pour améliorer la qualité et
l'efficience le gestion des organismes
de sécurité sociale pour permettre
d'offrir un meilleur service aux usagers
un meilleur
je vais commencer par la situation
financière actuelle de la sécu en la
mettant en perspective avec sa
trajectoire intérieure depuis les années
1990 à l'exception d'une très brève
période au tout début des années 2000
l'acide sécurité sociale connaît une
situation déficitaire
avant la récession de 2009 son déficit
s'élevait à 9 milliards d'euros au plus
fort de la crise donc en 2010 il a
atteint un niveau alors inédit de près
de 30 milliards d'euros et ensuite été
réduit de médias continuent de sorte que
l'équilibré a été presque atteint en
2018 et en 2019
une trajectoire de redressement qui
s'est ensuite infléchie je rappelle que
la loi de financement pour 2020 voté à
l'automne 2010 9 prévoyait un déficit de
5 4 milliards d'euros déjà une petite
reprise
vous le voyez là la rupture de la
tendance régulière de retour à
l'équilibré contre sociaux et donc
antérieurs à la crise sanitaire
mais celle-ci à son tour très
profondément et dans des proportions
jamais vues dégrader leurs perspectives
en 2020 je les dis le déficit des
comptes sociaux atteindrait un niveau
inédit de 44,4 milliards d'euros alors
messieurs les sénateurs d'où vient ce
montant historique il s'agit
essentiellement d'un choc sur les
principales recettes de la sécurité
sociale liée en partie aux conséquences
du confinement et dans une moindre
mesure une mesure tout de même très
significative de dépenses
supplémentaires essentiellement au titre
de l'assurance maladie
du côté des recettes elle chuterait de
27,3 milliards d'euros par rapport à la
prévision pour 2020 de la dernière loi
financement de la sécurité sociale
la masse salariale du secteur privé qui
constitue la principale assiette du
financement de la sécu il y avait en
effet de près de 8 % en 2020 contre une
prévision de croissance de 2 8% dans la
lfss 2020 à soi seul ça entraîne près de
22 milliards d'euros de pertes de
recettes attendu des dépenses elles sont
pour la plupart directement lié à la
crise sanitaire
elle provoque une progression massive de
l'ondam l'objectif national des dépenses
d'assurance mais de 7,6 pour cent je
rappelle que ces 2 45% qui était prévu
dans l air
ss de 2020 ce niveau est le plus élevé
depuis la mise en place de l'objectif en
selon la commission des comptes de la
sécurité sociale l'assurance maladie
supportera un surcroît de 15 milliards
d'euros de dépenses du fait de la crise
directement ces dépenses comprennent par
exemple des dépenses supplémentaires à
santé publique france notamment pour
l'achat de masques ô combien nécessaires
aux établissements hospitaliers aux
services médico sociaux mais aussi les
dépenses exceptionnelles d'anonymisation
d'arrêt de travail de réalisation de
tests actuellement tout à fait
indispensable une compensation des
pertes d'activités des professions
libérales
il faut préciser que ce surcroît
dépensés en partie compensé à hauteur de
4,5 milliards d'euros par une baisse
très forte d'une part de l'activité des
professionnels de ville et la
consommation courante de médicaments et
de dispositifs médicaux
dans tous les cas nous constatons que
l'impact de la chute brutale des
recettes et de l'augmentation des
dépenses la dette sociale est absolument
massif au titre de la seule année 2000
20 la dette augmenterait en effet
d'environ 30 milliards d'euros pour
atteindre 145 milliards d'euros sa
réduction intervenu entre 2016 et 2019
étant donc quasi effacée
dans ce contexte l'horizon d'extinction
de la dette sociale a été reportée d'une
décennie et demeure d'ailleurs assez
incertain la décision de transfert de la
dette à la cades est ce que j'aime aussi
les parieurs été prise sans visibilité
précise sur la trajectoire financière la
sécurité sociale or nous savons que la
crise sanitaire pourrait avoir une
empreinte durable sur les comptes
sociaux qu'elle affecterait aussi
potentiel croissance économique et donc
le niveau de recettes de la sécurité
sociale et donc je redis devant vous le
message
j'ai passé il ya peu de semaine son
collègue de conditions de fer social des
affaires des finances au titre de
président du haut conseil des finances
publiques
il nous semble qu'il faudra une nouvelle
trajectoire de référence du pib' à
travers une loi de programmation des
finances publiques qui pourrait être
voté au printemps prochain en même temps
que le programme de stabilité
lorsque nous aurons plus de visibilité a
à vrai dire ça nous paraît indispensable
on peut pas piloter les finances
publiques sans boussole sans cap sans
références solides
ce sera parfaitement inutile pour mieux
piloter l'évolution nos finances
sociales distinguer le conjoncturel du
structurel l'exceptionnel de l'ordinaire
c'est plus que jamais une nécessité pour
la bonne gestion de nos finances
publiques
les dépenses pour répondre à crise
sanitaire ne sont pas discutés elles
sont nécessaires
la courbe d'y devenir très clairement
aucune contestation de la légitimité de
ceux là quand on vit une situation
extraordinaire il faut des mesures qui
soit à la hauteur
mais voilà ces dépenses pérennes appelle
un effort accru de sélectivité pour en
améliorer la qualité la pertinence parce
qu'à défaut ça risquerait d'accentuer
l'écart structurel entre niveau des
recettes et ses dépenses à financer de
la même manière il sera important que
les mesures de régulation des dépenses
annoncées en 2021 à hauteur de 3,5
milliards d'euros soit plus amplement
documenté fasse l'objet aussi d'un suivi
rigoureux dans leur mise en oeuvre
face à la hausse des dépenses
l'augmentation nette des recettes
affectées au financement de la sécurité
sociale apparaît peu envisageable disons
en tout cas que ça ne me paraît pas être
l'air du temps les prélèvements
obligatoires en attaque en france 44 1%
du pib en 2010 neuf niveaux plus élevés
que chez nos principaux partenaires
européens
il n'est pas non plus souhaitable qu'on
pût la trajectoire budgétaire déjà très
dégradée de l'état de l'amputer de
certaines de ses recettes pour les
affecter à la sécurité sociale ou
va porter la charge de nouvelles
dépenses ce qui veut dire remettre les
finances sociales sur la voie l'équipe
structurelles 9 pas beaucoup d'autres
options que des recettes peut-être y
aurait-il quelque chose
non mais tout de même l'option
principale c'est de définir une nouvelle
trajectoire de dépenses qui permettrait
de maîtriser la hausse notre dette
sociale
le parlement arrêté l'été dernier le
principe d'un désendettement de la
sécurité sociale autour des déficits
cumulés sur la période 2020 2023
en limitant ce désendettement à 92
milliards d'euros
la cour relève toutefois que la
trajectoire de sol qui figure en projet
le financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2021 conduirait à ce qu apparaisse
en réalité un nouvel endettement cumulé
de l'ordre de 20 9 milliards d'euros à
la fin 2023 être près de 50 milliards
d'euros à la fin de l'année 2024
c'est une perspective qui présente pour
nous le risque de mettre en place ce que
nous ne recommandons pas un mode de
financement permanent de sécurité
sociale pour la dette car je les dis je
le redis aujourd'hui
je leur dirais tant qu'il le faudra je
leur dirais tant que je serai président
de la cour des comptes la soutenabilité
de notre dette publique doit être le
pilier un des piliers de notre future
stratégie financière
il faut donc et ce sera la deuxième
partie de mon propos identifier les
leviers qui permettent de remettre les
comptes de la sécurité sociale sur la
voie de l'équilibré à 10 ans sur la
qualité de la dépense autre boussole
pour notre stratégie financière dans la
décennie qui vient
nous avons étudié les résultats obtenus
ces dernières années dans la maîtrise de
leurs dépenses par les différentes
branches disant qu'ils sont globalement
positifs et ils doivent être soulignés
comme tel mais ils sont pas encore
suffisant surtout il ya des inégalités
des différences entre branches
je m'explique avec trois exemples si
vous le permettez du côté de la branche
famille la maîtrise des dépenses été
facilitée par l'inflexion de la natalité
depuis 2014 mais aussi par des mesures
opposants sur des choix clairs qui ont
visé à aider en priorité les familles
les moins favorisées et donc là nous
considérons que les pouvoirs publics ont
visé est rempli à un double objectif de
rigueur et d'équité le système de
retraite
de son côté a connu entre 1993 et 2000
14,5 réforme d'ampleur touchant les
régimes de base
en plus des hausses de cotisations c'est
la forme et agissent
vous le savez sur l'âge de départ à la
retraite la durée de cotisation sur le
niveau des pensions
elles ne suffisent toutefois pas assuré
à l'horizon de la fin la décennie
l'équipe du système mais elles ont
ramené l'évolution des dépenses un
rythme proche de celui du pib et là
encore il faut le souligner enfin les
dépenses d'assurance maladie ont vu leur
progression significativement ralenti
l'ondam rapporté aux pays bas était
stabilisé à change constant autour de 8
3 % ces dernières années son respect
avant la crise sanitaire étaient assurés
depuis 2010 la progression de l'ondam
depuis 2016 toutefois été desserrée ou
là de l'objectif de 3% pourtant prévu
par la loi de programmation des finances
publiques 2018 2022
ce qui vous montre à nouveau la caducité
de cette loi au passage après un premier
relèvement 2019 pour la stratégie ma
santé 2022 que la cour d'ailleurs
j'estime positive la crise des urgences
puis la crise hospitalières ont conduit
en 2020 avant l'épidémie a fixé un taux
de 2 45%
de son côté le plfss 2021 entraîne je
les dis une révision majeure de l'ondam
pour 2020 quai pour tes 7 6% conséquence
directe de la crise pour la cour ces
évolutions souligne les limites de la
maîtrise des dépenses de santé repose en
seulement sur mon âme
bien sûr un tel objectif reste
indispensable
nous y tenons d'ailleurs nécessaire de
développer pour les professionnels de
santé libéraux des outils analogue
comparables ce qui existe pour les
établissements de santé
mais ce pilotage ne peut pas suffire à
organiser une maîtrise du raz des
dépenses de santé qui soit à la hauteur
à la fois des besoins de nos concitoyens
des exigences d'équilibré que j'ai
rappelé en clair la contrainte
financière seuls sans rénovation du
système ne suffit pas le retour sur un
chemin d'équilibré de l'assurance
maladie nécessite donc des actions
structurelles lacourt déjà fourni un
certain nombre de pistes par le passé
elle développe trois grandes
illustrations
cette année l'une
concerne c'est le principal sans doute
les groupement hospitalier de territoire
un thème sur lequel vous avez sollicité
notre insistance de constater d'ailleurs
fière de mon audition devant la
commission des affaires sociales leur
autre assemblée à quel point ce sujet
était sensible pour les élus je n'ai pas
de doute qu'il sera aussi très sensible
pour vous qui représentez les
territoires je vais céder si vous le
permettez comme une parenthèse une
incise en tout cas la parole comme vous
l'avait annoncé à denis morin pour qu'il
vous présente les conclusions du rapport
réalisé par la cour demande votre
commission
car en effet c'est un sujet qui comme un
oral c'est aux rapports spécifiques que
nous avons fait à votre attention
merci de ce premier président donc avec
votre trac comme madame la présidente et
comme comme prévu je pense une incise
effectivement sur les relais j'ai acheté
travail que nous avons conduits à la
demande de votre de votre commission est
que nous avons conduits je crois de
façon particulièrement approfondie
puisque nous avons examiné et je
voudrais remercier les rapporteurs en
particulier nicolas pard annexes ici
présent la quasi-totalité des projets
médicaux partagé est disponible sur
marché et discuté à faire cent
vingt-neuf d'entre eux sur les 136 j'ai
acheté et nous avons également
approfondir le dialogue avec environ 500
personnes professionnels de santé élus
usagers dans treize j'ai acheté
regroupant soixante dix sept
établissements pour tester un peu nos
nos constats et noé nos préconisations
alors pour aller droit au but pour
répondre aux 2 questions à mme la
présidente que vous avez soulevé dans
votre propos liminaire est-ce que j'ai
achetés sont mis en place bruit et ce
qu'ils ont eu un impact sur l'offre de
soins non et je pourrais éventuellement
rester là mais je pense que vous exigez
que je j'argumente un peu plus me
semble-t-il donc les constats que nous
avons dressé portent d'une part sur
l'hétérogénéité des j'ai acheté il ya
130 si j'ai acheté aujourd'hui en france
beaucoup d'entre eux 28 sont adossés à
un chu on voit bien les avantages que ça
peut représenter notamment en terme de
démographie médicale de disponibilité
professionnels de santé sur un
territoire donné
le reste par conséquent non dispose pas
c'est déjà un premier clivage qui
qui est majeur dans leurs limites
géographiques beaucoup de jeux achetés
sont en réalité structuré autour dans
l'établissement support particulièrement
fragile je pense que le dialogue que les
ars ont noué avec les élus et les élus
locaux ont permis sans doute d'ajuster
les choses au plus fin des souhaits des
élus
c'est une très bonne chose naturellement
néanmoins dans beaucoup de départements
j'aurais cité en particulier monsieur le
site comme ça il y en a beaucoup
d'autres l'yonne la seine et marne et la
manche
à l'évidence des j'ai acheté un frein
départementaux qui fonctionne autour
d'établissements hospitaliers qui est
sont extrêmement fragiles et par
conséquent ne présente pas la qualité de
prise en charge que nos concitoyens sont
en droit d'attendre sur l'ensemble du
territoire ne contribue pas un avantage
à la correction des inégalités de santé
et ne répondent notamment pas un sujet
majeur qui est comme vous le savez dans
les territoires où l'offre de santé est
difficile c'est insuffisante la capacité
à prendre en charge en moins de 30
minutes environ un certain nombre
d'accidents de santé comme les avc ou
des problèmes cardiovasculaires
je citerai par exemple le fait que 38
j'ai acheté ne dispose d'aucun plateau
d'angioplastie que 24 j'ai acheté non
pas du nv alors que paradoxalement le
nombre du nv sur le territoire national
est 140 comme nous l'avons montré dans
un travail pour le round 1 d'il ya deux
ans à peu près équivalent non de
justesse que les découpages ne sont à
l'évidence pas les bons 46% des j'ai
acheté ne dispose pas d'hospitalisation
à domicile ce qui est évidemment par
rapport à l'orientation actuelle du
fonctionnement de notre système de santé
une défaillance majeure 21% d'entre eux
ne disposent pas de psychiatrie ce qui
pose la question de la participation des
établissements de ce type à l'ensemble
des j'ai acheté et enfin de façon sans
doute moins critique me semble-t-il 10%
que j'ai achetés ne dispose pas d'une
offre en obstétrique donc forte
hétérogénéité qui devrait de notre point
de vue sans la poursuite et
l'approfondissement du dialogue dans les
territoires entre les ars et les élus
être corrigé si c'est possible dans les
prochaines années
deuxième observation que nous mettons en
évidence me semble-t-il pour rester
encore une fois très très synthétique
dans la limite de la
6 que premier président rappelait tout à
l'heure une gouvernance qui est complexe
la loi prévoyait c'était je prends un
accord qui avait été passé entre le
gouvernement et entre l'exécutif et le
législatif
l'absence de personnalité morale et j'ai
acheté c'est probablement un temps du
raisonnement il faudra probablement
aller au delà c'est ce que nous un style
honda l'heure dans le dans le rapport
parce que cette absence de personnalité
morale et souffre de grandes difficultés
de fonctionnement
j'aurais simplement pour visualiser les
choses rappelé que pour un certain
nombre de décisions qui touchent par
exemple à l'adaptation du pmp ou à
l'adaptation des statuts certains
établissements certains j'ai acheté sont
obligés d'engager un processus de
consultation qui est extrêmement long
avec entre 50 et sans consultation
ce qui évidemment n'est pas totalement
de nature à accélérer la prise de
décision
alors parfois on le voit notamment même
si nous n'avons pas spécifiquement
étudié ce point à travers la crise
sanitaire
j'ai acheté qui ont le mieux fonctionné
et les professionnels de santé eux-mêmes
disent que ça a été un vrai plus sont
ceux qui sont les plus intégrés et par
conséquent ceux qui ne le sont pas et
qui sont restés dans une logique
beaucoup plus fédérative qu intégrative
présente de ce point de vue là un
certain nombre de défaillances enfin
troisième point et j'en terminerai par
là les j'ai acheté non pas comporté à ce
stade bien dire que la réforme est quand
même relativement récente
le sujet la coopération hospitalière
sujet qui remonte à très loin avec les 6
h je ne citerai aussi des cht de la loi
hpst de 2009
et puis bien entendu les j'ai acheté la
loi santé de 2016 donc c'est quand même
relativement récent et nous n'avons pas
noté à ce stade des faits restructurant
majeur de la mise en place et j'ai
acheté ce qui est fort dommage
rarement mise en place de la paix la
gradation des soins dans les territoires
ce qui est une vraie difficulté pas de
correction des inégalités de santé
nous avons observé que la répartition de
l'offre en vérifiant le en testant sur
un échantillon de j'ai acheté la
situation de l'offre en 2000 qu en 2014
la situation de l'offre en 2018 ou 19
nous avons vérifié comment love s'était
réparti entre les établissements support
jeu constitue demande le président mi
longs et les établissements
périphériques et nous avons observé dans
quelques cas un phénomène de
concentration vers l'établissement
support des 3 beaucoup de cas et à notre
grande surprise le phénomène inverse un
déport d'activité vers des
établissements périphériques qui pour
autant rencontre toujours les mêmes
difficultés et en particulier
disponibilité entre deux professionnels
de santé nous avons noté peu de création
de pôles interétablissements moins de 5%
des jets acheter nous avons noté une
stabilisation du nombre de salles
d'intervention chirurgicale
évidemment notre idée c'est plutôt qu'il
faut aller réduits en particulier celles
qui ont peu d'activité il ya 3300 salle
d' intervention chirurgicale dans le
pays il y en avait trois mille trois
cent en 2014 y en a un petit peu moins
2018 une cinquantaine mais dans un
nombre d'établissements qui est inchangé
et qui est même en légère croissance 6
111 établissements en 2014 et 614 4
années quatre années plus tard donc on
voit bien qui est plutôt léger achetés
ont plutôt eu pour effet en gros de
stabiliser de figer l'offre sauf dans
quelques cas relativement marginaux et
donc on peut par conséquent de ce point
de vue à ce stade
et encore une fois c'est un constat qui
est très préliminaire puisque on est
deux ans après quatre ans après la loi
santé aujourd'hui on peut constater que
l'offre de santé n'a pas été
substantiellement modifié pourtant il ya
un certain nombre de sujets qui
mériteraient je pense un
approfondissement de la réflexion de
notre point de vue est de mon point de
vue premier point quid de l'organisation
des transports sanitaires quel rôle et
j'ai acheté pourrait-il jouer dans ce
domaine
deuxième point quid du régime des
autorisations pourrait-on imaginer que
les autorisations passe auger acheter et
non pas aux établissements qui le
constituent il ya une réflexion en cours
sur la la réforme des autorisations je
pense qu'elle est en cours depuis une
dizaine d'années et d'ailleurs dont
peut-être un jour
pourra-t-elle aboutir si elle aboutit ce
serait bien je pense de se poser ce
genre de ce genre de questions troisième
point
comment s'assurer de la disponibilité
des personnels médicaux et non médicaux
sur un territoire donné auprès de
l'ensemble de la population de ce
territoire
par conséquent c'est un peu l'idée de
l'hôpital hors les murs que j'ai acheté
pour est de ce point de vue là incarné
en mutualisant notamment un certain
nombre de professionnels qui
en situation démographique critique pour
l'instant et pour quelques années encore
on imagine que j'ai acheté pourrait
jouer un rôle de ce point de vue là et
nous concluons le rapport en soulignant
que de notre point de vue n'est j'ai
acheté les plus efficaces si on veut
aller au bout de la logique de la
réforme sont légers acheter plus intégré
nous plaidons vigoureusement pour des
directions communes d'établissement au
sein de j'ai acheté direction commune ça
existe depuis très très longtemps
en règle générale moi j'avais observé en
région rhône-alpes ya quelques années
que les élus quand j'étais déjà et reste
que les élus n'avaient pas
systématiquement de prévention à l'égard
de ce mode d'organisation qui était au
contraire de nature à apporter un plus
notamment lorsque le directeur était à
la fois directeur d'un établissement
très solide dans un territoire donné et
pouvaient par conséquent apporté un
concours un établissement qui l'est
moins et encourager les mutualisations
entre eux en trois ses établissements je
pense que c'était une bonne façon de
voir j'ai un peu le sentiment à lire le
rapport que nous vous avons adressé les
travaux d'instruction qui ont été
conduits que de ce point de vue là il ya
plutôt une régression et nous sommes par
conséquent relativement inquiet voilà
donc encourager plutôt l'intégration
dans les jets acheter qu'une logique
générative jeu pourrait conclure en
disant que c'est ça m'a pas montré que
le sujet est simple il en est un petit
peu la coopération hospitalière comme de
l'intercommunalité et par conséquent et
par conséquent c'est au moins un sujet
aussi difficile
là je sais comme un ressort de votre
commission merci beaucoup d'autres
attentions du sionisme en acide monsieur
promis je sais pas si c'était une
critique ou
c'est un président de l'agglomération je
me prononcerai pas sur le sujet merci je
suis poursuivre sur le contenu du rallye
dans lequel nous développons en plus de
géant cité 2 aux illustrations pour agir
sur les ressources structurelles les
dépenses de santé
la première concerne la simplification
du système de financement des activités
hospitalières notamment les deux
stations dites pour mission d'intérêt
général et d'aidé à la
contractualisation des migac et les
fonds d'intervention régionaux le firent
dont disposent les ars pour financer des
actions santé publique d'intérêt
régional
ces deux sources de financement
représenté en 2009 un total de près de
11 milliards d'euros avec des
chevauchements entre enveloppe
financière un empilement croissant de
lignes budgétaires la simplification de
ces dispositifs et une répartition plus
claire des responsables dans leurs
attributions entre l'admistration setra
les arrêts sont à nos yeux donc
indispensable la deuxième illustration a
trait aux dispositifs médicaux
ces derniers concernent un vaste
ensemble de produits et de services qui
vont du simple pansement ou dispositifs
implantables de haute technologie qui
peuvent être fournies ou prescrit à
l'occasion d'un soin ils sont utilisés
dans un nombre croissant de maladies
elle qu'une dépense correspondante
évalué à 15 milliards d'euros qui
progresse d'environ 4% chaque année soit
beaucoup plus vite que l'ensemble des
dépenses retracé dans l'ondam jusqu'à
présent les mesures de maîtrise ont
pratiquement porté sur les prix de ces
dispositifs
il faut désormais selon nous agir en
parallèle sur la pertinence de la
prescription sur l'optimisation des
achats par les agissements de santé et
sur la lutte contre les abus les fraudes
en écrivant ses actions dans un cadre
plus réel voilà quelques exemples de
champs dans lesquels des efforts de
maîtrise et de sélectivité des dépenses
sociales sont possibles d'autres bien
sûr existe nous pensons dans tous les
cas qu'il est essentiel dans la mise en
oeuvre de ce type de mesure de respecter
une exigence de sault lite
ce point est fondamental car selon nous
ces efforts doivent être adaptées à la
situation de chacun et en particulier
veiller à celle concitoyens défavorisés
plusieurs chapitres du rapport illustre
ainsi d'un essayer de mieux cibler
certaines prestations de solidarité j'ai
cité les choix faits dans la gestion des
prestations familiales qui ont été
partout en clair en faveur des familles
défavorisées
le montant du complément familial a par
exemple augmenté de 39% depuis 2013 avec
vous le savez une majoration
supplémentaire pour les familles
nombreuses les plus modestes en matière
de retraite
plusieurs mesures ont cherché à atténuer
les effets des réformes successives pour
les faibles pensions comme la majoration
du minimum contributif ou ti des
trimestres cotisés en 2004 où la mise en
place à partir de 2010 des mesures en
faveur des carrières longues mais des
mesures telles que l'indexation des
salaires utilisé pour le calcul de la
retraite sur les prix favorise les
assurés à carrière pleine est ascendante
et peuvent pénaliser ceux qui ont subi
des pertes de chômage ou toucher des
salaires plus faibles les pensions de
retraites prévoit cependant des
dispositifs de minima bâtiments
importants pour nos concitoyens qu'ils
perçoivent une très petite retraite
ce sont des mécanismes de solidarité
interne différents régimes de retraite
dont l'objectif est de porter comme le
nom l'indiqué montant minimum la pension
servie à certains audacieux sous
certaines conditions
ils interviennent donc en amont du
minimum vieillesse
il concerne environ aujourd'hui un
nouveau retraités sur cinq donc très
important la majoration de pension
qu'ils entraînent représente en moyenne
130 euros par mois pour les assurés du
régime général ou pour les
fonctionnaires qui en bénéficient c'est
donc précise katif quand on est toute
petite retraite de 500 à 600 euros
ils représentaient au total 8,7
milliards d'euros de versements en 2018
nous avons observé que la finalité de ce
dispositif avait évolué et devaient
désormais faire l'objet d'une
clarification conçu historiquement pour
augmenter la retraite des salariés qui
ont une carrière complète le minimum
contributif du régime général
bénéficient aujourd'hui principalement
des personnes qui ont des carrières à
temps partiel ou incomplètes enfin et
surtout la cour a relevé la complexité
des dispositifs de mima existants qui
conduit à ce que près d'un million de
personnes ayant pris leur retraite ou
alors dossier rester durablement en
carafe en attente de règlement définitif
nous précisons donc de préconisons donc
de procéder dans les meilleurs délais
aux différentes harmonisation qui
mettront de garantir à l'ensemble des
bénéficiaires la perception définitive
des montants qui leur sont dues les
visions de solidarité qui implique aussi
du côté de la branche famille et
d'accroître l'efficacité des dépenses
d'action sociale aux côtés des
prestations familiales et les caf
pourtant défaire un soutien financier un
soutien technique au développement de
services et d'équipements destinés aux
familles notamment des crèches et des
centres de loisirs et c'est un soutien
qui est bien sûr fondamentale la branche
famille n'a cependant pas pu atteindre
les objectifs fixés de création de cent
mille places en crèche le taux de
réalisation est de 63 % seulement
par ailleurs vous le savez des
inégalités territoriales persistent
notamment faute d'émulation suffisamment
fine des besoins
au vu de l'importance des financements
publics mobilisés même 5 8 milliards
d'euros en 2010 9,1 milliards de plus
qu'en 2012 nous recommandons d'apporter
à ces dispositifs les améliorations
indispensables pour offrir aux familles
un service de qualité sur l'ensemble du
territoire
enfin il faut faire progresser la
qualité et l'efficience de gestion des
organismes de sécurité sociale et c'est
notre dernière orientation
il faut d'abord et en priorité réduire
le nombre
le montant des erreurs qui affecte le
versement des prestations sociales dans
le cadre de ses travaux de certification
des branches du régime général
la cour examine chaque année le degré de
conformité des prestations versées aux
règles de droit applicables pour
l'exercice 2010 9
ces travaux font état d'un montant d'
erreur caractère définitif d'au moins 5
milliards d'euros toutes branches
confondues
ces erreurs peuvent être faits tonique
détriment des finances sociales c'est le
cas pour 90% de celles qui affectent les
prises en charge des frais de santé
aussi se faire au détriment des
bénéficiaires de prestations comme pour
les deux tiers des erreurs qui affecte
versement des retraites c'est un
anomalie résulte soit des données
déclarées par les bénéficiaires soit des
opérations de gestion des caisses de
sécurité sociale elle même il faut noter
que la fréquence et la portée financière
des erreurs sont en nette augmentation
ces dernières années par exemple la
portée financière des erreurs liées aux
données déclarées pour les prestations
de la branche famille atteint 3,4
milliards d'euros en 2018 contre 2
milliards d'euros en 2014 a bien sûr il
faut distinguer les erreurs des fraudes
dont nous avons parlé devant vous il ya
quelques semaines mais il ya aussi des
points communs dans le traitement des
deux questions la cour recommande d'
accroître l'automatisation des processus
de gestion de dématérialisation des
déclarations pour éviter de verser des
prestations qui sont non conformes à la
réglementation et comme nous l'avons
souligné dans notre communication devant
vous relative à la lutte contre la
fraude aux prestations sociales
il faut aussi fermé les possibilités
systémique de fraude et renforcer les
actions de contrôle a posteriori avec
des effectifs plus importants
enfin notre rapport évoque différentes
recommandations à l'appui la nécessité
d'adapter l'organisation des branches du
régime général et de moderniser la
gestion du recouvrement social par le
réseau des urssaf voilà madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur
général mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
j'en ai terminé avec la présentation de
notre rapport sur la sécurité sociale je
voudrais à nouveau pour conclure insisté
sur notre message principal est le
résumé d'une certaine façon la priorité
face à la crise sanitaire a été donnée
au soutien de notre système de santé
c'était nécessaire c'est légitime
justifié mais dès que les circonstances
le permettront et nous l'espérons le
plus tôt possible
il est impératif de remettre rapidement
la sécurité sociale sur un chemin
d'équilibré financier durable pour
assurer la soutenabilité des dettes
sociales pour éviter de pénaliser les
générations futures donc il faut bien
distinguer qui est très court terme la
gestion de la crise de ski et le retour
une trajectoire qui est une trajectoire
durable
il n'est pas exact cours est proposé de
tailler dans les dépenses sociales comme
j'ai pu le lire ici ou là c'est une
caricature bien sûr mais l'accord est
aussi là pour assurer la bonne gestion
des deniers publics et pour assurer que
dans le moyen terme
en effet le têt publique soit sous
contrôle que son évolution soit
soutenable d adaptation en profondeur
seront nécessaires pour atteindre cet
objectif et ce soyons conscients mais
voulait être que plus ces adaptations
seront différées plus elles seront
difficiles à mettre en oeuvre
merci pour votre attention et je me
tiens avec les magistrats qui
m'entourent avec denis morin à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le premier
président merci à monsieur denis morin
je vais passer tout de suite la parole
au rapporteur général puis le rapporteur
des différentes branches et ensuite
alain milon que plus spécifiquement
ciblé ce matin sur les j'ai acheté et
ensuite on fera des questions regroupées
de collègues pour compléter cette
audition monsieur le rapporteur général
merci et madame la présidente merci
monsieur le premier président et le
président mesdames et messieurs les
conseillers
j'ai toujours évidemment plaisir à vous
écouter parce que on apprend un certain
nombre de choses
je dois dire que comme on a eu une
audition assez récente
on avait déjà effectivement un peu
ébauché en quelque sorte les les
constats que vous avez fait pour une
part mais effectivement comme vous
l'avez souligné fortement on assiste à
une forte dégradation en 2020 des
comptes de la sécu mais moi ce qui me
paraît le plus inquiétant c'est la
trajectoire financière pour deux mais
depuis 2000 21 jusqu'en 2024
on constate une stabilisation du déficit
au niveau de 20 milliards environ
d'euros et est ce que ce déficit vous
paraît réaliste au vu des hypothèses de
croissance vous avez souligné la
nécessité effectivement de revoir la
trajectoire financière de d'avoir une
loi sur ce point qui reprennent on
compte effectivement des données
réaliste actuelle et tu fais aussi de la
loi de grand âge enfin autonomie qui
doit
être votée au début de l'année prochaine
dans ces conditions quelle est la vision
de la cour sur la possibilité vous avez
évoqué le sujet aussi d'éteindre la
dette sociale qui ne cesse de croître et
qui risque de croître encore jusque 2033
donc voilà la première question pour
faire face à cette situation
votre rapport préconise une meilleure
maîtrise de la dépense sociale j'ai
entendu effectivement un certain nombre
de recommandations mais qui ne me
paraissent pas de nature suffisante pour
équilibrer les comptes à venir en tous
les cas j'aimerais si vous pouviez
effectivement nous aider dans ce domaine
soyez les bienvenus
c'est de préciser les domaines les
montants dans lequel on pourrait agir
rapidement efficacement pour
réduire en quelque sorte ce déficit
ce que je crois que si vous considérez
qu'afficher un retour à une progression
de l'ondam de 2,3 à compter de 2023 sur
une base de dépense de 2022 est excessif
quel serait pour vous en quelque sorte
les dépenses sur lesquelles il faut se
pencher en priorité
enfin j'en viens point que vous avez
aussi évoqué c'est à dire votre rapport
aux parle des erreurs voire des fraudes
quand elles sont intentionnels qui sont
dans l'ex augmentation ces dernières
années
et tu as ta vous citez chiffre de 5
milliards
effectivement moi je reviens à votre
dernier rapport sur les fraudes
justement aux prestations jamais oublier
nos plus les fraudes aux cotisations
d'ailleurs qui existe aussi et que la
cause ainsi un chiffre est à peu près à
6 à 10 milliards ce qui n'est pas rien
donc vous imaginez les besoins de
financement de la sécurité sociale
votre notre commission bien entendu va
relayer les propositions que vous avez
fait à cette occasion lors de l'examen
prochain
de la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale vous avez notamment appelé
chaque organisme à se doter de moyens
pour évaluer la fraude les regrettez
vous le savez que vous n'ayez pu estimer
cette fraude parce que vous avez pu voir
comme moi que les fantasmes continue et
ne cesse d'amplifier
de croître et d'embellir on est à 40 50
milliards des organes de presse s'en
font état il y avait un livre qui a été
publié je n'en dirai rien mais je n'en
pense pas moins
je dis qu'il est indispensable et urgent
d'avoir un organisme comme le vôtre peut
qu à nous nous allons nous y employer
mais avec nos moyens qui puisse estimer
donner des chiffres pour essayer de de
faire taire en tous les cas de données
essayé d'approcher la réalité de ces
erreurs et de cette rose alors je crois
d'ailleurs que de son côté la cour
devrait je vous pose la question est ce
qu'elle est prête à s'impliquer à son
niveau de contrôleurs pour certifier
annuellement les montants que publieront
des organismes sinon c'est
être juge et partie ça n'a jamais été
effectivement une situation à gré
intéressante et qui assure effectivement
la vérité et la véracité des chiffres
donc voilà de quoi en avoir terminé avec
le petit merci merci donc on s'il
pouvait répondre déjà au rapporteur
général on va faire rapporteur par
rapporteur et ensuite on regroupera les
réponses monsieur le rapporteur général
je vais effectivement répondre par une
question par question d'abord sur la
dégradation des comptes de la sécurité
sociale la trajectoire financière dans
le temps qui lui était imparti avant la
publication du rallye la cour n'a pas pu
examiner la cohérence entre les
hypothèses macro et qu'une gouvernement
les trajectoires plus rénale la sécurité
sociale à l'horizon 2024 présente annexe
b du plfss 2021 à noter néanmoins que
comme précisé dans ladite annexe b
la trajectoire des dépenses 2022 2024 du
plfss 2020 repose sur l'hypothèse d'une
évolution tendancielle dépenses
consacrées à l'autonomie de 4% par an ce
qui ne prend donc pas en compte des
mesures nouvelles en dépenses qui
pourraient être décidées dans le cas
d'une prochaine loi sur le grand âge
l'autonomie enfin s'agissant de
l'extinction de la dette sociale cours
indique dans le chapitre 1 du real ce
qu'à l'horizon 2024 déficit de la
sécurité sociale prévues par le plfss
2021 dépasserait de près de 50 milliards
d'euros lé montant de reprise de dette
par la cades est ce sont 13 milliards au
total prévus par la loi du 7 avril 2001
relative à la tête social autonomie bref
quand je regarde tout ça vous vous
demandez si c'est réaliste
réaliste oui peut-être même pas complet
mais pas forcément raisonnable
voilà un peu le pour résumer le
sentiment que nous pouvons éprouver sur
la maîtrise des dépenses sociales
qu'on soit clair déterminer la part que
la collectivité doit consacrer à la
santé ce n'est pas à la cour d'en
décider ce choix relève du gouvernement
et du parlement et non non pas du tout
entier telindus une fois ce choix fait
en revanche le rôle de la cour c'est de
vérifier que la dépenses ainsi financées
pertinente efficace efficiente
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire dans
mon présentation introductive la norme
d'évolution des dépenses d'assurance
manier fixée par la loi de programmation
des finances publiques pour la plate
2018 2022
un taux dont dame avait été fixé à 2 3%
le contexte économique résultant de la
crise sanitaire fait se croque center
pas contesté par le gouvernement que
cette loi est à nos yeux caduque et donc
le haut conseil de finance publique
recommande préparer une nouvelle loi de
programmation et si la situation sin
salida le permettre d'en débattre dès le
printemps prochain dans l'agenda
politique qui est le nôtre par ailleurs
ça me paraît quand même tout à fait
raison nous en avons besoin
ça me paraît indispensable et c'est dans
ce cadre que le taux de référence de
l'ondam aura à être fixés les hypothèses
d'inflation seront également à prendre
en compte pour le reste nous connaissons
les multiples gisements d'efficience que
brossel secteurs la santé sur la
trajectoire nous avons un programme
d'économies annuelles sur la dame qui
est représenté 3,5 à 4 milliard d'euros
par an c'est encore ce que prévoit le
gouvernement pour 2021
mais une fois passée la crise il faudra
redéfinir le dit programme d'économies
et à cet égard nous traçons des pistes
dans leur halle et dans l'érable
successifs qui permettent de nourrir ses
programmes et vous les trouverez dans le
rapport enfin sur votre dernière
question
bien sûr la cour se penchera
attentivement sur les estimations du
montant de la fraude qui établiront la
cnam et la cnav
lorsque celle ci examinera dès l'année
prochaine et suites données par le
ministère des solidarités la santé zone
sécurisée serrer sa communication à
votre communication
quatre commissions sur la fraude aux
prestations sociales
l'aco a bien entendu tout à fait disposé
à échanger avec la cnav et la cnam sur
les méthodes qui pourraient être
employées pour procéder à ces
estimations
dans sa communication à votre commission
elle propose notamment d'estimer le
montant de la fraude par redressement
statistique des résultats des contrôles
et ciblées en fonction de certains
critères qui conduisent détecter des
préjudices
dès avant sa communication sénat sur la
fraude aux prestations sociales à courre
entraîné un dialogue régulier avec la
cnaf sur l'estimation du montant de la
fraude
comme vous savez la branche famille est
aujourd'hui la seule à établir chaque
année une estimation du montant de la
fraude elle le fait depuis 2010 j'ai
bien noté votre frustration j'ai noté
aussi que notre rapport connu la limite
que nous avons subies qui fait qu'il n'a
pas servi autant que nécessaire de
garde-fous surenchère qui sont
considérablement accrues puisqu'on
parlait de 15 milliards non j'ai vu lu
quelque part le chiffre de 50 milliards
il faut un moment donné couper la tête à
ce canard et arrêté ses fantasmes et
donc je crois
nous sommes en effet disposé
à reprendre ce travail quitte mais là je
n'engage que moi mais je le fais en me
tournant vers le président de la chambre
à prendre quelques risques
je crois qu'il faudra le faire il peut
être approximatif
encore une fois il faudrait qu on est
totalement un travail partagé avec le
ministère mais je pense qu'il serait un
président que l'accord était ma sixième
chants de travail sur une estimation
tout le mois parce que nous sommes très
très loin de ces chiffres
et pour le coup le fait de rester dans
son ce clair-obscur empêche d'éclairer
ce débat est encore une fois d'éviter
des fantasmes je ne sais pas là je
m'avance un peu président mais je suis
sûr que nous pouvons le faire et donc
pour terminer avec la cour wii va
s'impliquer dans le suivi des
recommandations du rapport et qu'elle
pourra le faire à travers ces travaux de
certification comme vous le demander
monsieur le rapporteur se rapporcher
noter le très vif intérêt qu'il a
souligné j'ai noté ce petit limite cette
frustration qui tenait à notre rigueur
méthodologique
mais je crois qu'il faut que nous
poursuivions ensemble cette réflexion
parce que nos concitoyens sont
extrêmement attentifs ces questions est
tout à fait à juste titre et j'en
profite pour vous remercier à nouveau
d'avoir suscité cette réflexion tout à
fait importante qui montre au passage à
quel point les relations entre la cour
et le parlement permettre de faire
progresser le débat citoyen
merci je vais passer maintenant la
parole à corinne imbert rapporteur pour
la branche maladie
merci le plaisir merci monsieur le
premier président de la cour je vais
revenir notamment sur lamballe ont damé
le fonds d'intervention régional l'étude
de la cour des comptes sur les dépenses
d'assurance maladie entre 2010 et 2019
relève à l'instar d'un récent rapport de
nos collègues catherine desrochers et
rené paul savary sur l'andam que la
régulation ne naît pas n'est pas
suffisante pour un pilotage stratégique
de la dépense de santé et vous l'avez
déjà évoqué vous avez aussi évoqué qu'on
ne peut pas piloter les finances
sociales sans boussole alors comment
avez vous abordé dans cette analyse le
principe du découpage en sous-objectifs
de l'ondam autour duquel se polarisant
partie des débats
celui ci selon vous est il satisfaisant
à l'heure où la notion de parcours de
santé devient une notion très importante
est-ce que c'est satisfaisant aussi face
aux enjeux de décloisonnement entre les
soins de ville et à l'hôpital
et de quelle manière la programmation
pluriannuelle soumise au parlement que
vous préconisez pourrait-elle permettent
de dépasser cette approche aujourd'hui
essentiellement sectorielles concernant
concernant le fonds d'intervention
régional le firme l'étude de la cour
sur le firent géré par les agences
régionales de santé et les dotations
migac pointe s'agissant du fir des
disparités historique dans la
répartition des dotations une logique
peu redistributive faudrait-il selon
vous est le cas échéant de quelle
manière engager un rééquilibrage
territorial plus volontariste de ses
dotations et sous réserve d'une plus
grande transparence que vous appelez
également de vos voeux un renforcement
substantiel du fir pour accroître les
marges de manoeuvre dans les actions
conduites dans les territoires serait
t'il selon vous au souhaitable et si oui
dans quelles conditions
enfin peut-être un petit mot donc aussi
sur en lien avec évidemment ce rapport
sur l'application des lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale
la cour appelle de ses voeux des
réformes plus intense pour exploiter des
multiples gisements d'efficience de
notre système de soins
quels sont les enseignements selon vous
de la crise sanitaire actuelle en clair
est-ce que le virus aurait un petit
avantage en tout cas auraient nous
aiderait quelques gisements d'efficience
percevez-vous dans la gestion sanitaire
de cette crise je vous remercie
je peux pour la parole je considère que
la présidente me le passer et je
remercie la rapporteure je lui dis que
la cour partage sa préoccupation sur les
entraves au déploiement d'une logique de
prise en charge des patients selon la
notion de parcours de santé
toutefois bien gardé les des
inconvénients sont sont moins du fait du
pilotage macro financiers à travers
l'ondam qui est
un instrument de dialogue démocratique
avant tout on ne peut pas régler tous
les problèmes avec les objectifs de
l'ondam ce qui est problématique ce sont
les mécanismes de financement des soins
individuels qui sont fondés aujourd'hui
essentiellement sur la rémunération
séparer des actes des différends
internationaux soit nous pensons que
pour les parcours de soins elle répond
c'est d'abord dans la mise en oeuvre des
différentes réformes du financement
permettant de passer d'une rémunération
uniquement l'activité une hausse des
rémunérations fondées sur le suivi des
patients
donc nous travaillons beaucoup sur la
prévention en santé notamment en lien
avec une autre assemblée
la conséquence des soins qualité nous en
avions des travaux sur ces sujets qui
pourront donner lieu à une publication
l'année prochaine la programmation
pluriannuelle pour y revenir à laquelle
nous pensons n'est pas celle du
découpage l'ondam en secteur c'est une
autre problématique nous voulons signer
c'est celle du caractère très limitée
des éléments dont dispose le parlement
poursuivre dans la durée l'impact des
différentes réformes engagées sur les
dépenses de santé annexes 7 du plfss
fourni des éléments de la formation en
audio limitée généralement d'air dans un
cadre annuel alors que nous savons que
la pertinence de l'action soit
déterminante dans sa santé mais peut
être analysée que dans une perspective
pluri annuel pour ce qui concerne votre
question sur le firent nous avons en
effet relevé les écarts très importants
dans le montant de dotation par habitant
qui peuvent varier dans un rapport tout
simplement du simple au double voire
plus - 2 721 euros par habitant bretagne
pays de loire ou de france compte plus
de 247 en ile de france ou dans les dom
est certainement la place à une prise en
compte plus importante de cette
problématique des disparités entre
régions
il faut agir dans un calendrier a fixé
vous parlez de la transparence
c'est effectivement le sens d'une
recommandation faut donner plus de marge
de manoeuvre aux ars qui sont les mieux
placés
plus plus que l'administration centrale
pour apprécier les besoins dans les
territoires nous avons relevé que
beaucoup de crédit des lits aux as et
reste un cas des migac soit en fait
fléchés pour donner plus de marge de
manoeuvre aux ars là puisque nous
proposons consistera à faire basculer
les enveloppes dead a continué de
contractualisation pardon dont le firent
ça suppose toutefois que chaque ars
parce que tout n'est pas parfait se met
en capacité de piloter un volume de
concours plus important est de bien le
piloter ça existe des capacités
d'évaluation dès capacités de contrôle
du bon usage des financements accordés
enfin par les gisements d'efficience
votre question me permet de ne revenir
sur un point important
nos travaux d'instruction dont ce
rapport résume les constats parce que en
fait c'est une consolidation très
nombreux travaux de la 6ème chambre ne
portent pas notamment en matière
d'assurance maladie sur l'année 2020 et
donc a fortiori je les dis dans mon
instruction il ne porte pas sur la
gestion de la crise sanitaire
quand nous parlons du dimanche
déficiences ce que nous voulons dire
c'est que le système de santé
une fois sorti la crise sanitaire se
retrouvera avec les mêmes problèmes que
nous connaissions avant la crise la cour
et bien d'autres les ont identifié de
longue date ce qu'il entend conduire
également identifier les multiples
visions déficiences qui peuvent exister
parmi les actions nécessaires
ce rapport comme celui de l'an dernier a
fait des propositions précises et
souligné entre autres exemples la
nécessité de réduire le coût des
produits sanitaires notamment en
agissant sur les prix des produits les
plus anciens de réduire les surcoûts de
dialyse sujet sur lequel la cour
également travaillé de responsabiliser
davantage assurée et les médecins
prescripteurs d'arrêts de travail
rationaliser l'organisation des
transports sanitaires d'accélérer et on
le retrouve autour des j'ai acheté la
coopération hospitalière mai
nous sommes arrêtés sur le sujet avec le
président bras voilà quelques-unes des
pistes que nous jouions et encore une
fois la crise sanitaire n'efface pas les
problèmes existants les aggrave plutôt
avant de passer la parole à notre
collègue rené paul savary sur la
vieillesse
moi je l'abordé un sujet qui est celui
de vous avez parlé du coût des produits
de santé
mais la place de l'innovation dans dans
les projections que l'on peut faire
parce que c'est un rapport que l'on
avait fait au sénat avec véronique
guillotin yves daudigny sur l'axé prix
qu'aux aux médicaments innovants
cervelle sujet et on voit bien que le
fait que le budget soit annualisé ne
permet pas d'anticiper parfois les les
coups d'innovations l'impression d'un
ralentissement parfois dans une
discussion fait pour des raisons
purement budgétaire est ce que vous avez
travaillé sur ce sujet de d'anticipation
du coup à venir de l'innovation je pense
notamment en oncologie ou dans d'autres
terrains dans d'autres pathologies du
nid nous ne vont pas travailler sur le
sujet dans ce stade
mais effectivement je sais que le hca
mme travail travail sur ce point donc
nous aurons sûrement l'occasion
d'apporter aussi une contribution à
cette réflexion tout en notant quand
même que au moins s'y prend l'exemple du
dernier traitement innovant
et par exemple le traitement contre
l'hépatite c est parfaitement du sujet
on n'avait pas eu de difficulté à
l'inclure dans la mécanique d'ensemble
de l'ondam et de la régulation du
système du système
les médicaments et des dispositifs et
des dispositifs médicaux
laura pollan plus de difficultés sur
d'autres types de traitements innovants
extrêmement coûteux mais en principe
l'état outillés pour aborder ces sujets
notamment avec le sait au ps et avec
tous les dispositifs touchant la liste
en sus qui permettent de financer ces
molécules pour autant que évidemment les
concours arrive aux établissements
hospitaliers au delà de la tarification
t2 à la fois c'est un point qui tout à
fait fondamentale pas seulement
d'ailleurs sur les médicaments sur
beaucoup d'autres sujets l'innovation en
général en santé et sur lequel on sera
sûrement amené après les après des
travaux du hk main à intervenir
également les paul savary merci est
question effectivement sur les régimes
de retraite vous avez une courbe dans
vos documents qui montrent bien que les
différentes réformes que ce soient les
mesures d'âge la revalorisation des
pensions sur sur l'inflation nos
panneaux solaires etc arrivent quand
même à faire que jusqu'à présent les
retraites représenté 13 8 % environ du
pib quelle là il va y avoir une
dégradation qu'elle me quelles
préconisations faites vous pour essayer
de d'appliquer ce que vous avez formulé
monsieur le premier président à savoir
qu'il va falloir prendre des mesures
pour corriger la trajectoire or hier
soir à l'audition de d'olivier ferrand
on a bien entendu surtout aucune mesure
ça risquerait d'être en contradiction
avec le plan de relance est pour
l'instant on fait une dérive assumer des
comptes sociaux
avec la crise mais on ne prend pas de
mesures correctrices
alors est-ce que vous avez quelque chose
à préconiser deuxième question si vous
permettez c'est sur les minima des
minima sociaux s'éveille qu'il ya des
disparités de régime à le micro pour les
régimes salariés
le mica pour de mémoire ces deux bêtes
pour les régimes fonctionnaires le père
m pour la pour le port pour les agricole
qu'est ce que vous préconisez pour qu'on
essaie d'harmoniser un petit peu plus
parce que jusqu'à présent on a beaucoup
travaillé là dessus mais c'est depuis
2000 tout ce que l'on dit qu'il faut
harmoniser tout ça alors est-ce que vous
avez là aussi quelques idées
supplémentaires pour gagner un petit peu
de temps et faire en sorte que on arrive
à harmoniser un certain nombre de
dispositifs parce qu'on voit bien la
complexité de changement de mode de
calcul vers un système universel en
point par rapport aux annuités par
rapport aux six derniers mois pour ce
qui concerne les régimes d des
fonctionnaires donc est-ce qu'il serait
pas temps de proposer des choses si vous
avez des idées en ce domaine la merci de
nous en faire part et puis un dernier
point en ce qui concerne en ce qui
concerne également l'information des des
retraités on voit bien que ils n'ont pas
tous la formation nécessaire et qui ne
font pas appel aux 10 aux différents
dispositifs existants on l'avait vu avec
les regrette
les retraites agricoles notamment où il
ne faisait pas appel à la spa par
exemple vous dire que la spa égale
recours sur succession donc ça peut
quelquefois faire en sorte qu'on ne
fasse pas appel à ce dispositif
il n'empêche une meilleure information
serait importante est ce que vous avez
là aussi quelques idées de
préconisations dans le cadre de votre
réflexion je vous remercie le président
merci à présent de monsieur le sénateur
je ne vais pas rentrer dans le débat sur
le timing sur le calendrier des
décisions à prendre
bref encore une fois je le dis pas
illogique qu'il y ait un temps pour la
réponse à la crise sanitaire la crise
économique la crise sociale mais le
temps de du retour et une trajectoire d'
équilibre financier soutenable viendra
il doit venir et c'est aussi l'enjeu du
débat démocratique que nous appelons sur
noye de programmation de finances
publiques qui doit remettre les choses
dans une perspective pour le coup à la
fois réaliste et raisonnable qui
essaient de soutenabilité de la dette
publique
comme vous le savez le conseil d analyse
des rotations des retraites le cor a été
saisie en août dernier par le premier
une nouvelle évaluation de la situation
financière du système de retraite à
l'horizon de 2030
le résultat de cet exercice de
projection devrait être rendue publique
dans les tout prochains jours la
question de l'intensité de la durée de
la crise son caractère durable seront
pour le coup par rapport à cette
question de calendrier aux évoquions on
peut le penser crucial je note que le
premier a demandé au cor d'évaluer le
déficit conjoncturel lié à la crise et
de le distinguer du déficit structurel
qu'il conviendra de réduire
naturellement c'est pas la courde
recommandé à ce stade l'utilisation de
tel ou tel levier dans le chapitre iii
du rapport que nous avons présenté ce
matin nous avons analysé les impacts
relatifs toutefois des différents
leviers mesures d'âge et dur et bien sûr
nous avons aussi souligné l'importance
des règles d'indexation utilisé dans le
calcul des retraites
l'an dernier nous avions fait remarquer
que le dispositif de départ anticipé
pouvait être resserrée sans que ça nuise
à l'équité dans sorte dans le chapitre
que nous avons consacré cette année à
l'analyse rétrospective de dépenses
d'assurance vieillesse
nous avons noté que les efforts étaient
plutôt mal répartie m'agresse certains
dispositif spécifique carrières longues
pénibilité élections nombre d'heures
pour valider un trimestre ce sont les
personnes aux salaires les plus bas et
hors de l'emploi pour lesquelles les
mesures générales d'âge de durée
cotisations eu le plus d'impact et la
cour pense que cet enseignement là
devraient être prises en compte pour
l'avenir ça rejoint l'exigence de
solidarité d'équité dans l'effort que je
suis développé dans mon propos liminaire
concernant les disparités sur la réforme
des retraites
vous comprendrez la grande difficulté
pour moi de vous apporter la réponse que
pourtant vous souhaitez parce que la
cour n'a pas l'habitude mais je pense
que c'est sage de commenter les réformes
lorsqu'elles sont encore en cours de
discussion et pour le coup vous êtes des
hommes et des femmes politiques je
l'étais il est tant de paramètres qui
conduisent la décision de mettre à
l'agenda une réforme qui n'est pas
pertinent pour la cour de se prononcer
s'agissant des disparités entre les
régimes nous avons fait une
communication à l'assemblée nationale en
juillet 2019 sur gimont spéciaux de la
ratp sncf des industries électriques et
gazières qui soulignait quelles que
soient les options retenues le futur en
matière de systèmes de rotana recherché
trois objectifs 1 une accélération de
l'alignement avec les règles de la
fonction publique
lesquels sont appelés à se rapprocher du
régime général de transparence accrue
des financements et 3 meilleure
efficience dans la gestion des tests de
retraite ans en 2016 la courbe également
rendu un rapport sur la retraite des
fonctionnaires ou le mettait en avant
différents levier d'évolution de
meilleures parties ont détaillé cette
année dans un rapport que nous vous
présentons ce matin sur un sujet certes
plus circonscrit qui suit dé minuad
pensions nous rappelons que la règle
d'écrêtement qui s'applique sous la
halle au minimum de pension des
fonctionnaires n'est pas appliquée sans
le tilt pour des raisons informatiques
une rupture d'égalité qui doit être
corrigée rapidement
c'est le sens d'une recommandation très
explicites et puis disons le tout de
même bah nous pensons que effectivement
un système universel ne prononce pas sur
lequel camp
nature corriger certaines des disparités
que nous constatons en matière de minima
de retraite et que à défaut d'avoir un
tel système il faut procéder rapidement
aux harmonisation qui permet de corriger
ces disparités que vous soulignez que la
cour relève également pour ce qui
concerne les nikon ont calculé les
effectivement de la réponse était des
caisses concernées la direction de la
sécurité de régler enfin cette question
rapidement nous formons le voeu que
notre grande nation puisse avoir la en
effet utile ça doit être une priorité de
gestion pour les caisses afin qu'elle y
met les moyens nécessaires pour ce qui
est de l'information des assurés
je me félicite que nos analyses
rejoignent en tout point vos
préoccupations et vous votre propre
regard sur ce sujet qui n'est rien
d'autre que celui de l'accès effectif de
nos concitoyens leurs droits sociaux
donc je n'ai rien à ajouter à ce que
vous pensez et dit puisque nous le
partageons intégralement
merci monsieur le cédant élisabeth
doineau pour la branche famille oui
merci madame la présidente je voudrais
commencer par des remerciements à
l'adresse du premier président de la
chambre ainsi que l'adresse de monsieur
denis morin moi j'étais vraiment en
appétence par rapport à l'ex l'instit de
ce rapport sur les j'ai acheté en est
tous sur notre territoire concerné par
ces nouvelles formes de coopération et
on se posait beaucoup de questions j'ai
toujours d'ailleurs été très très déçu
que dès les débuts les établissements
privés ne soit pas à la table je dirais
de conférences ou même titre que les
établissements publics
on a vu pendant cette crise sanitaire
combien cette coopération entre public
et privé était indispensable et je pense
qu'il faudra changer les choses alors je
reviens à la branche famille puisque
c'est mon rôle
vous avez consacré une large part de ce
rapport vous avez même comment consacré
un chapitre aux dépenses d'action
sociale sur la branche famille voulzy
indiqué que l'objectif fixé dans la
coach 2013-2017 de correction des
inégalités territoriales dans le
développement des modes de garde n'a pas
été atteint vous constatez que la
prestation de service unique des caf qui
soutient financièrement les crèches ne
procurent plus un effet de levier majeur
à la création d'équipements ou de places
d'accueil
les créations de places étant largement
liée à l'implication des collectivités
du secteur privé j'avais eu souvent
l'occasion d'ailleurs de dire combien
l'excès de normes l'excès d'encadrement
mettez en difficulté les collectivités
pour justement s'associer pleinement
financièrement à la création de
nouvelles places de crèche lacoche
2018-2022 fixe de nouveau un objectif
d'égal accès aux modes de garde et la
cnaf a mis en place à cette fin des
bonus mixité sociale et inclusion
handicap on l'avait vu
l'année dernière avez vous évalué en
fait le déploiement de ces dispositifs
sont ils selon vous de bon levier pour
améliorer l'efficacité de soutien aux
crèches et comment mieux évaluer
l'efficience de ses mesures de soutien
ma deuxième question porte sur le manque
de régulation de l'offre d'accueil du
jeune enfant sur le territoire avec des
risques de concurrence entre structures
parce que s'il manque parfois de place
il y à aussi dans d'autres lieux
concurrence entre structures vous
indiquez en effet que le reste à charge
des familles varie selon qu'une crèche
est financé par la psi ou par la page
d'ailleurs c'est toujours commander des
prestations qui sont peu et mal
appréhendé par le grand public il faut
le dire sera peut-être remettre ça en
tout cas sur le tapis pour ans pour
simplifier les choses vous proposer de
mieux coordonner l'installation des
structures d'accueil sur le territoire
pourriez vous nous dire comment cela
pourrait s'organiser parce que tous nous
avons été élus le coup et nous avons
tous vu ce type de difficulté comment
mieux coordonner l'installation des
structures d'accueil
pourriez-vous en outre faudrait
faudrait-il selon vous simplifier ses
financements en unifiant par exemple les
modes de financement des places par la
branche famille quel que soit le type de
structure
merci merci on va répondre sur la
famille et puis la réponse y ont déjà
acheté se fera lorsque le président
muller a posé ces questions
ont blessé peut-être le président de
mort à compléter je prends note de ce
que vous avez dit sur les j'ai acheté
tout en relevant au passage que ce n'est
déjà pas si simple pour le public qui
ajoutait le privé sera une mobilisation
encore plus forte
mais néanmoins en logique
votre remarque est absolument
pertinentes sur l'action sociale en
faveur des familles je rappelle ses
objectifs c'est d'intégrer la baisse de
natalité de mieux cerner les besoins des
ménages dans les territoires de mieux
contractualisé entre les acteurs de
mieux articuler ce qui résulte des
prestations légales et ce qui résulte
des prestations extra légale nous
n'avons pas encore évalué les dernières
réformes qui ont des monnaies à la cnaf
des modalités de financement de l'offre
d'accueil des jeunes enfants viennent
d'être rénovés avec pour objectif
d'encourager la création de places est
de réduire les écarts de financement de
crèches
c'est une évolution qui était nécessaire
mais il reste encore trop il est encore
trop tôt pour en connaître tous les
impacts sur la création de places le
contrat enfance jeunesse qui donnait au
versement de la prestation de service
enfance jeunesse est un outil
vieillissant qui générera une très forte
théologie de financement à partir de
2020 et remplacées par de nouvelles
conventions de territoriale globale
signé entre la carpe et des
collectivités partenaires avec un bonus
territoire qui vise notamment à réduire
les écarts de financement entre crèche
et à soutenir les politiques et les
moins riches eu une enveloppe destinée à
la petite enfance est prévue en 2022 à
hauteur de 769 millions d'euros ce qui
est implique par exemple qu'une crèche
pourrait financer en complément de la
paix ait su par le bonus territoire
s'il remplit les conditions par les
bonus mixité sociale et l'inclusion
handicap donc d outil de flexibilité en
quelque sorte est enfin forfait pour le
développement des nouvelles offres de
services est également prévu peut-être
denis tu ajouter quelque chose
voilà non nos éléments de réponses aux
questions non c'est le premier précédent
1,1 million pour les j'ai acheté
uniquement mais merci n'y aura pas
beaucoup de questions il ya beaucoup de
constats merci monsieur premier
président et merci à la cour pour
l'ensemble des rapports que vous avez pu
nous faire dans le cadre de six années
que j'ai passées à la présidence de
cette commission et et merci pour ce
rapport sur les jeux achetés
j'aimerais avant vous parlez de ça vous
dire que redevenant sénateurs de base
dans le cas de la commission je me sens
beaucoup plus libre qu'en étant
président et donc je vais avoir des
paroles qui ne sont plus celles d'un
président mais qui sont celles d'un
sénateur de base la commission des
affaires sociales ce qui me permet de
vous dire donc le constat que vous avez
fait sur les j'ai acheté sur morin est
particulièrement intéressant surtout
quand vous dites que finalement la
plupart des j'ai acheté sont construits
autour d'établissements support que vous
nommez fragile
s'ils sont fragiles mais toi de le dire
mais c'est un avis personnel
c'est probablement dû à l'hyper
administration qui a été mise en place
durant des années au niveau des hôpitaux
et aussi à l'orthodoxie financière qui
était mise en place pour ces hôpitaux en
leur demandant de moins dépenser en
demandant de dépenser par rapport à t2 à
ses activités rentables et pas faire le
reste
et en leur demandant aussi d'accueillir
des populations qui n'avaient peut-être
pas obligatoirement les moyens de
financer des actes auxquels ils avaient
besoin
cette auto ici financière a mis en
danger l'existence même des hôpitaux
on le voit bien actuellement et
j'ai ce sentiment très net que l'urgence
sanitaire a bon dos actuellement mais
qu'en fait l'urgence anicet sanitaire
n'est que le reflet d'une insuffisance
d'offres de soins publics consécutive
justement à des restrictions budgétaires
de plus en plus forte depuis des
dizaines d'années maintenant bien
évidemment alors quand je lis votre
synthèse vous dites que les missions
principales et j'ai acheté c'est
l'efficacité d'offre de soins la
rationalisation des modes de gestion et
quand vous faites le constat vous dites
que les j'ai acheté n'apporte pas de
réponse suffisante à question de l'égal
accès aux soins sur le territoire que
les j'ai acheté n'ont pas d'impact
significatif sur l'offre de soin à la
consommation de soins et que les j'ai
acheté qui devrait permettre de mener à
terme l'organisation territoriale
hospitalière publique de son arrivée à
mener à terme cette organisation
territoriale de l'offre de soins
publique
donc comment est ce que je peux dire ça
monsieur premier vice-président est ce
que la bonne gestion des finances
publiques qui était l'un des termes que
vous avez utilisé dans le cadre de votre
exposé ça doit être simplement le
contrôle des dépenses
est ce que il ne peut pas y avoir des
propositions pour essayer de faire en
sorte qu'on continue contre les dépenses
en particulier
vous avez parlé d acte de redon dans les
fraudes et cetera mais également
peut-être aussi essayer de trouver un
nouveau système de recettes
supplémentaires pour permettre à
l'ensemble de la population d'avoir un
accès à tous les soins y compris les
soins innovants
c'est pas une question c'est juste une
observation
je suis pas sûr d'ailleurs que ce que je
dis là entraînera l'accord de l'ensemble
de mes collègues
enfin j'ai le sentiment très net
actuellement qu' on ne peut pas
s'empêcher de
considérer que le système de soins
français tel qu'il avait été conçu par
pas parle à la suite de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
ce système de soins français était
probablement au niveau du système l'un
des meilleurs du monde et je souhaite
que ce système puisse continuer mais
pour ça il faudra certainement monsieur
le premier vice-président trouver nous
aider à trouver de nouvelles recettes et
pas uniquement à avoir des restrictions
dans les dépenses j'ai deux petites
questions à vous poser quand même
maintenant de votre enquête conclut donc
à une absence de phénomène de
concentration excessive de l'activité d
acheter au profit de l'établissement
support et vous affirmez même dans votre
étude que cght ont un effet centrifuges
qui fait donc les activités
d'établissement supports vont plus vers
l'établissement qui sont autour de
l'établissement support est ce que cela
est réel ou y at il au moment de la mise
en place d j'ai acheté des stratégies
qui ont été mises en place de
contournement de ses activités qui
devrait rester dans l'établissement
support et ne pas aller dans les
établissements secondaires
cette question me semble importante et
puis la deuxième question elle est un
peu plus encore vous déplorez fort
justement que le modèle d'intégration
composé par les j'ai acheté perpétue le
cloisonnement l'offre de soins et vous
dites donc que vous suggérez que j'ai
acheté au ghsr gestoci gcs pardon on si
l'on additionne une forme supplémentaire
de groupement à force de mettre des
couches supplémentaires comme au niveau
intercommunalités n'y at il pas un
danger de mettre trop de couches il ne
serait-elle pas simplement plus utile de
créer une seule catégorie de groupements
dans lequel seraient intégrés comme l'a
dit même doisneau
l'offre privée et l'offre aussi de
médecine de vide avant pour épargner je
voudrais compléter un peu ce qu'a dit le
président mi longs parce que c'est une
question aussi que que souhaite imposer
c'était lorsque vous avez travaillé on
avait travaillé nous avant la loi santé
demain à mme buzyn sur sur un état des
lieux un peu de ce qui avait été décidé
auparavant laissé pts les plateformes
territoriale et puis les groupement
hospitalier territoire et ça rejoint la
question d'un million comment vous voyez
l'établissement du lien justement entre
les j'ai acheté qui sont restés quand
même des groupements des hôpitaux
publics du territoire essentiellement
sur la mutualisation de moyens et sans
aller sur une vision de l'offre de soins
territoria les communautés
professionnelles territorial de santé et
où là il ya la médecine de ville et les
établissements privés ça rejoint un peu
cette forme un peu unique pour être
celle à l'échelon d'un territoire et
populationnelle de la rénovation le soin
de soi bon de laisser denis morin pour
nos questions sur les j'ai acheté je
vais peut-être répondre à la question
préalable donc quelque sorte du
président milon en disant que la liberté
fondé sur l'expérience permet d'avoir
ensuite une parole redoutable mais
d'autant plus précieuse donc nous
continuerons ce dialogue entre nous dans
ces nouvelles conditions et votre parole
sera écouté entendu pour le dire
différemment
j'essaie devant une parole libre bien
qu'étant encore en fonction de premier
président et même pour quelques années
puisque c'est
prises en charge assez récente de ma
part il est clair que s'agissant de la
réflexion sur les finances publiques ne
gêne en rien un peu le propos panne et
moi nous entrons dans une période
nouvelle qui implique incontestablement
un changement de paradigme
nous avons vécu par exemple c'est la
réponse à la crise financière de 2008
avec un régime qui a été au contraire le
durcissement des règles je n'ai connu
comme commissaire européen pendant
quelques années avec la fixation du tout
paquet six pack avec le traité de
stabilité de croissance et filmé tout ça
et non pas derrière nous parce qu'on a
toujours besoin de l'aide des finances
publiques mais on va vivre durablement
avec un régime de finances publiques qui
n'a rien à voir avec celui que nous
avons connu ces dernières années
nous ne retrouverons pas la cour
l'étamine dans son rapport sur les
perspectives et la situation des
finances publiques en juin un niveau de
dettes publiques comparables ce qui
existait avant la crise avant les années
et encore il ya plusieurs trajectoires
finances publiques qui peuvent aller à
une dégradation durable du niveau de
l'endettement nous ne retrouverons pas
un niveau déficit inférieur à 3 % du pib
probablement avant trois ou quatre
années
quand nous regardons le plf pour 2021
nous voyons que nous restons sur des 5,7
ou des chiffres de cette donnée là et
nous avons mis en place face à la crise
des dépenses absolument massive que ce
soit au niveau national ou au niveau
européen et ce qui fait que la
définition que j'essaye de donner de la
cour des comptes dans ce contexte
qu'elle doit être sérieuse oui la bonne
gestion des deniers publics
c'est notre raison d'être et on a besoin
dans le débat public une institution
comme la nôtre qui est là précisément
pour rappeler en effet que que chaque
citoyen a droit
l'information était y ait un jugement
sur sur le service public
je souhaite que la cour évolue vers plus
d'évaluations de politiques publiques
vers davantage d'accompagnement de la
décision publique j'ai lancé tout un
chantier de réflexion sur l'avenir des
juridictions financières la cour et
aussi les collectivités et les chambres
régionales des comptes
mais je crois dans ce contexte là il
faut que la cour soit sérieuse on va pas
attendre qu'elle soit laxiste ou
fantaisistes mais pas qu'elle soit père
fouettard et pour nous toute dépense
publique n'est pas un ennemi ne vont pas
être basé uniquement sur des critères ou
sur des normes ou sur des principes qui
sont des principes rigides
c'est la raison pour laquelle je crois
en effet qu'il faut se tourner vers deux
notions que j'ai évoqué dans mon propos
liminaire la première notion c'est la
question de la soutenabilité de la dette
ça semble être une boussole pour
l'avenir parce que financer une économie
aux finances et un système de sécurité
sociale à crédit durablement sommes ici
entre personnes sages
d'un certain âge pour beaucoup d'entre
nous ont bénéficié ces systèmes de
production ciel nous sommes
confortablement à l'abri mais pensons à
la jeunesse qui elle ne l'est pas qui
aura à rembourser cette dette le moment
venu parce que nous racontons pas
d'histoires un moment donné nous avons
rendez-vous collectivement avec la tête
elle ne sera pas annulée elle sera pas
intégralement monétiser ne sera pas
intégralement mutualisé donc cette
question de soutenabilité de la dette
est un paramètre deuxième c'est la
qualité de la dépense publique je dis
bien la qualité c'est là où l'on
retrouve les notions d'efficacité
d'efficience de pertinence de de
sélectivité dans la direction de la
solidarité doit travailler assure va
vous m'interrogez sur la question des
recettes bois tout à fait franc s'est
pas exactement le champ de compétence de
la cour des comptes je le constate
mais nous avons à côté de nous une autre
institution que je préside également en
ma qualité premier président de la cour
qui est le conseil des prélèvements
obligatoires qui veut d'ailleurs délivré
la semaine prochaine un rapport sur très
intéressant sur la fiscalité des
entreprises
mais en la matière disons le les choix à
faire ce sont des choix collectifs
salaires ne sommes pas dans l'air du
temps d'une augmentation massive des
recettes est ce que pour autant le débat
public le débat politique là dessus est
interdite évidente est également
d'ailleurs sur qui devrait supporter cet
effort là donc cours à sa place
s'efforcera sans rigidité avec
c'est d'intelligence de la société aussi
de participer à ce débat sur l'avenir
nos finances publiques dans un contexte
repensé qui implique de notre part aussi
un changement de paradigme changement de
paradigme sans pour autant renoncer à
notre raison d'être qui est tout de même
de nous assurer que la dépense publique
est bien dépensé
on dépense beaucoup en ce moment j'ai lu
dit c'est pas illégitime
mais plus on dépense mieux on doit
dépenser presque pas penser que nos
concitoyens accepte que ses dépenses
énormes soit faite sans la moindre
contrepartie et sans le moindre contrôle
ils ont des exigences là dessus ils ont
raison tony j'avoue que j'ai du mal à
prendre le relais après propos aussi
aussi définitif si je peux dire est
essentielle si je juge applique cette
démarche peut-être à l'hôpital j'ai
envie de dire qu'une fois qu'on aura
dépassé la crise j'espère effectivement
on espère tout ça c'est assez rapidement
on sera confronté quand même à la
nécessité de cerner le coût de
fonctionnement de l'hôpital
et peut-être que les juridictions
financières qui contrôle aujourd'hui à
la fois l'hôpital public et les
cliniques privées pourront apporter un
certain nombre d'éléments intéressants à
cet égard nous commençons nos contrôles
voyons déjà un certain nombre de choses
deuxième question sur le terrain
déficiente peut-être nous pourrons aussi
éclairer le débat qui est de savoir si
on ne demande pas à l'hôpital trop de
choses nous avons fait un travail nous
peut-être vous avez gardé la mémoire sur
l'encombrement des urgences
je dirais pas que c'était un travail
prémonitoire qui annonce à la crise d
urgence mais nous avons en tout cas
montré les timides progrès qui ont été
accomplis en 50 avions déjà abordé ce
sujet cinq ans avant mais en même temps
la poursuite de la progression accélérée
la fréquentation des urgences qui est
grave aujourd'hui un des points d'entrée
majeur de l'hôpital et qui est
évidemment engorgé parce que troisième
point là encore sur le terrain
déficience tout quand même bien
reconnaître que la médecine de ville
c'est qu'un très fortement désengager de
la prise en compte d'un certain nombre
de contraintes en particulier de la
permanence des soins et que le sujet des
déserts médicaux et toujours pas
traitées
aigrefeuille quand on est dans un
territoire il ya des déserts médicaux
est bien la seule solution souvent c'est
de pousser la porte de l'hôpital
donc c'est pas forcément pour répondre
millions mais en tout cas pour appliquer
peut-être au sujet plus restreint de
l'hôpital un certain nombre de points
le coot l'efficience et par conséquent
aussi les relations ville ville hôpital
sur les sur les j'ai acheté je crois
quand même que on a identifié
effectivement un effet centrifuge dans
quatre cas sur dix mais un effet quand
même de concentration sur
l'établissement support dans six cas sur
dix devaient être le schéma n'est pas
complètement univoque
il est plus partagé probablement
d'ailleurs la concentration sur les
établissements support en particulier
dans les territoires où il n'y a pas
suffisamment de professionnels de santé
ou qui sont dans une situation
démographique difficile s'explique par
la situation de la démographie il est
probable plus facile de bénéficier de
professionnels de santé en nombre
insuffisant notamment pour faire
fonctionner des services lorsqu'il ya
des normes à respecter quand l
établissement support centre de j'ai
acheté car la périphérie pour des
raisons pour des raisons évidentes
donc ça c'est un premier un premier
point donc on donne plutôt une vision
plus équilibrée
il n'y a pas d'effet de concentration
systématique sur l'établissement support
mais les choses sont plus sont plus
répartie deuxième observation même si on
n'aborde pas complètement ce sujet dans
le rapport mais vous vous posez la
question je suis pas certain d'être en
capacité d'apporter une réponse de jeu
mon sentiment c'est que il faut
probablement faire progresser
l'organisation de l'offre publique
je ne suis pas certain qu'on puisse dans
une même structure dans un même j'ai
acheté associer systématiquement l'offre
privée dont la logique n'est quand même
pas tout à fait la même
on a pour ce qui est du fonctionnement
des établissements privés aujourd'hui
souvent des stratégies de groupe de
grands groupes capitalistique nnomo coup
sûr d'ailleurs côté qui finalement n'ont
pas grand chose à voir avec les logiques
territoriales et de prise en charge le
contrat de service public qui sont
celles du secteur public c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'un secteur public
hospitalier et donc j'ai toujours été
réticent à l'idée de dire il faut aussi
associer l'offre privée al'inverse dont
j'ai acheté à linverse
au niveau de la rs il est clair qu il
importe d'avoir la vision quand on
définit notamment les projets
territoriaux des projets régionaux de
santé dans la vision globale du secteur
public et du secteur privé au niveau de
la région et des territoires mais en
revanche pour ce qui est de la
construction d acheter je suis plutôt
réticent la seule la seule réserve et
donner vos congés croix dans le rapport
c'est la psychiatrie qui tient au fait
que historiquement le secteur privé non
lucratif a toujours été présent dans ce
dans ce créneau et que souvent ne pas
être en capacité d'associer une
structure de ce type à la réflexion sur
l'organisation de l'offre est un
problème c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
explique comme je l'évoquais tout à
l'heure que prennent un danger acheter
sur deux ne comporte pas de de prise en
charge au titre de la de la psychiatrie
et en fin d'année observation je trouve
que c'est compliqué de faire fonctionner
les la coopération hospitalière depuis
très longtemps
manifestement on s'oriente quand même si
rien ne bouge sur les jeux achetés vers
un échec très comparable à celui qui
avait été observé sur les cht laisser
pts nous avons salué cette initiative
comme le rappelait tout à l'heure le
grenier président qui renvoie aux
annonces déjà un petit peu ancien de la
santé 2022
c'est compliqué aussi visiblement
l'objectif 2000 je crois est loin d'être
loin d'être atteint le dernier que j'ai
à l'esprit c'est vince et pts qui
fonctionne peut-être qu'on a dû
interroger la cnam on a dû progresser
depuis et qui remonte à avant la crise
sanitaire
donc ça se déploie et une grande
négociation conventionnelle
interprofessionnel qui est qui a permis
de donner le top départ
je pense qu'il faut laisser les
démarches se développer je suis pas
certain qu'il faille d'ores et déjà les
croisés en tout cas c'est c'est ça me
ferait probablement qu'accroître la
complexité du sujet en revanche nous
plaidons vigoureusement ce qui n'est pas
forcément un message simple je le
conçois tout à fait dans le rapport sur
les j'ai acheté pour des démarches de
direction commune et au-delà direction
commune de fusions d'établissements qui
sont d'ailleurs amorcé nous l'avons noté
dans une vingtaine de j'ai acheté mêmes
de regroupement de la gestion de l'offre
sur le j'ai acheté doté d'une
personnalité morale ce qui suppose
évidemment un certain nombre
d'évolutions législatives que par
location vous éclairer je veux dire
merci à vous monsieur président alors
deux deux collègues victoire jasmin et
puis laurence cohen donc successivement
et la réponse
ensuite oui merci m
bref beaucoup madame la présidente âge
et j'ai deux questions alors la première
vous l'avez évoqué les problèmes qui
seraient liées aux pertes en et au
pilotage alors de savoir si vous avez
actuellement mis en place les axes
d'amélioration concernant la
compatibilité entre les différents
systèmes d'information parce qu'on l'a
vu par le passé vous avez eu de
nombreuses difficultés
je veux citer le rsi qui n'existe plus
mais par rapport au récit en tout cas
vous avez évoqué les problèmes de
retraite et aussi les fraudes certaines
de ces problèmes étaient liés aux
difficultés que vous aviez concernant la
probabilité vers l'ensemble des systèmes
d'information de vos services et avec
des conséquences quand même grave et que
vous connaissez donc de vous devez
savoir alors là c'est la première
question à la deuxième question vous
avez parlé également des recettes
alors là il outre les difficultés qu'il
faudrait trouver des recettes mais je
crois aussi qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait
une véritable politique de prévention et
intensifier la prévention
aujourd'hui parce que vous avez parlé de
changement et changer de paradigme c'est
vrai qu'il ya une certaine prévention
qui se fait mais en loi beaucoup plus
que jamais prendre en compte ces
difficultés là parce qu'en fait avec la
situation sanitaire que nous connaissons
nous avons vu apparaître une nouvelle
comme de décès précipité je dirai pas ce
qu'il ya des personnes qui normalement
avec une espérance de vie telle que nous
la connaissons de nos systèmes devraient
pouvoir en vie plus longtemps
eh bien on parle beaucoup de comorbidité
alors maintenant tout le monde sait
qu'il ya à cause de ses co morbidités un
nombre important de personnes qui sont
décédées
alors votre rapport ne porte pas sur la
que sanitaire mais je crois qu'il va
falloir évidemment tenir compte de ces
éléments là pour faire des réajustements
et permettent lee est véritablement une
politique pertinente cohérente pour la
prévention et la dernière chose avait
évoqué aussi les mygales les
financements pour les missions d'intérêt
général
alors là c'est un vrai sujet il faut
vraiment travailler sur ce sujet là
parce qu'en fait vous avez parlé de
crédits fléchés qui serait disponible au
niveau des ars pour les établissements
et qui pourrait déterminer évidemment
usage toutefois il y à un sujet
concernant de plus en plus les contrats
d'exclusivité parce qu'il ya des
équipements de plus en plus sur les
marchés qui sont des équipements avec
des contrats d'exclusivité tout
simplement parce que les les consommer
les consommables ou tout ce qui est lié
celle de la maintenance en fait tout est
fermé
donc ce sont des contrats fermés et
quelquefois conseiller semi fermée je
vais vous parler par exemple pour les
équipements de laboratoire mais dans
d'autres disciplines également et bien
de plus en plus aucun autre fournisseur
ne peut fournir pour un équipement
données ce qui génère des surcoûts
considérables
donc là aussi laissé me gago
c'est bien de les avoir et dans le cadre
de l'innovation madame la présidente l'a
évoqué il faut des financements mais si
on utilise avec l'innovation des
équipements fermi avec des contrats
d'exclusivité sur l'ensemble des
consommables l'ensemble des réactifs si
celle-ci s'agit de laboratoire mais
aussi dans les services de soins il y a
aussi cette même problématique
donc il y à un véritablement travailler
là dessus pour permettre à la recherche
et à l'innovation de se faire parce que
nous voyons à la réalité aujourd'hui
nous sommes tributaires dans bien des
domaines à d'autres pays alors qu'en
france il y aller chercher il ya des
programmes de recherche ne trouve pas
suffisamment les clients
man nécessaires pour pourvoir mettre à
disposition des personnes ressources que
nous avons la chance d'avoir ce qu'il
faut et ce serait vraiment dommage qu'on
ne puisse pas travailler davantage pour
une concurrence pour la concurrence
une concurrence de qualité de pertinence
et d'efficience je vous remercie
merci madame me cohen oui merci je suis
là je peux cacher merci madame la
présidente merci pour pour vous exposer
moi je j'aimerais quand même avoir
beaucoup plus d'éléments sur ce que vous
avez dit en disant il est absolument
nécessaire que la sécurité sociale
prenne des mesures après après
effectivement les les dépenses qui ont
été faites pour faire face à la pandémie
prennent des mesures structurelles
parce qu'il faut arrêter de creuser de
creuser la dette
mais monsieur le premier président moi
je suis un peu interloqué voire choqués
par cette analyse
parce que nous vivons un système de
santé et notamment au travers de
l'hôpital mais pas qu'eux qui souffre et
on a les démonstrations à l'appui de des
sedin d'économies et que ce sont des
mesures à court terme qui sont
draconiennes pour le présent et pour
l'avenir si on ne prend en compte que la
question de la pandémie en disant bon
cette fois-ci hockey l'ondam explose
mais on va reprendre les choses en main
après c'est une catastrophe parce que
aujourd'hui il manque des lits
d'hospitalisation aujourd'hui il manque
des professionnels et il faut donc
ouvrir des lits il faut embaucher il
faut former ça coûte de l'argent
donc je ne partage pas votre analyse
disant plus on dépense plus on appelle à
la dépense en matière de santé il me
semble que notre première obligation
notre première priorité c'est de
répondre aux besoins en santé
on voit ici par exemple que toujours au
travers de cette crise de l'aco vides il
y a eu des déprogrammations d'opération
et nous avons eu des échos ici parce que
nous sommes nombreux à participer à la
commission denquête nous avons eu des
témoignages nombreux de professionnels
qui nous disent que ça un coup c'est un
coût humain bien évidemment pour les
personnes qui n'ont pas été suivis mais
ça va avoir un coût pour la sécurité
sociale
donc je trouve que votre votre rapport
n'anticipe absolument pas les choses il
se place uniquement sur résorber la
dette ça ne me semble pas être une bonne
idée
deuxième deuxième point je suis étonné
alors évidemment un rapport ne chasse
pas à l'autre nous avons eu le rapport
l'an dernier de la cour des comptes qui
parmi les recommandations et vous ne
reprenez pas vous-même et j'aimerais
bien avoir des explications à ce sujet
donné la piste des 90 milliards de
niches et notamment dont 66 milliards si
mes souvenirs sont bons d'exonérations
de cotisations patronales
donc ça c'est une piste de refinancement
de de la sécurité sociale alors que
finalement dans votre rapport vous
affirmer qu' il faudrait réaliser des
économies et à terme ne plus alourdir la
dette sociale quitte à faire payer un
peu plus les patients ça me semble pas
être une recommandation qui
correspondent à ce qu'on attend d'un
système de santé enfin j'aimerais avoir
peut-être un peu plus d'éléments sur les
j'ai acheté parce qu'en fait vous dit
tout ce que
finalement peu de responsables
politiques ont assumé à savoir que la
création des j'ai acheté c'était
essentiellement pour faire des économies
or là vous l'affirmé dans votre dans
votre rapport
et en même temps vous dites que les
effets escomptés ne sont pas ne sont pas
au rendez vous donc là encore c'est une
c'est un élément me semble-t-il danalyse
important pour ne pas être seulement
guidé bien sûr qu'il faut des dépenses
qu'ils soient justifiées mais je ne vois
pas qui ne les justifient pas mais il ne
faut pas être guidé seulement par cette
boussole
quand on parle de santé de santé de nos
concitoyennes et de nos concitoyens
parce qu'après on alourdit encore plus
plus fortement les des pensions le voilà
avec la pandémie je vous remercie
un an nous allons continuer avec
stéphane artano et ensuite michel
meunier et ensuite la douce merci madame
la présidente temps j'aimerais revenir
au chapitre 11 du rapport annuel
d'application sur la loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale concernant le
réseau des urssaf
évidemment c'est un rapport sur
l'application des lois qui ont été
votées
il n'empêche qu'on peut quand même se
projeter peut-être par rapport une
activité une actualité contemporaine
vous noté notamment dans ce chapitre un
élargissement continue des missions des
urssaf ont entendu doit quand même qu'il
y afférentes de chantiers qui sont
inaboutie avec un certain nombre de
challenge et notamment celui de
l'extension du périmètre de la collecte
je crois qu'aujourd'hui les urssaf c'est
quasiment 75 % des prélèvements sociaux
obligatoires avec notamment dans la loi
de finances 2020 un certain nombre
d'extensions de collecte pour cette
cette entité dont cadre de la réforme de
la santé au travail qui devrait arriver
dans les mois qui viennent charlotte
lecoq notre collègue député a préconisé
une fusion des cotisations de la
cotisation nationale accident du travail
avec les cotisations aux services de
santé au travail pour n'en faire qu'une
seule et a préconisé que ce soit les
urssaf qui soit en charge du
recouvrement de cette cotisation unique
nous avons une occasion et pascale gruny
macro rapporteur de pouvoir échanger
avec le secrétaire d'état
santé au travail hier après midi sur ce
sujet et nous avons relayé ce que la
commission des affaires sociales a
adopté dans son rapport c'est à dire la
plus grande réserve sur le fait que ce
soit les urssaf qui soit collector d'une
possible cotisation unique alors au
regard de votre constat au chapitre 11
j'aimerais avoir votre regard objectif
sur cette perspective qui ne nous
enchante guère à ce stade je vous
remercie
merci michel meunier si madame la
présidente
moi j'ai une cuisse mais merci monsieur
le premier président de la cour des
comptes
j'ai une question très précise à aborder
sur un sujet particulier c'est
généralement notre rapporteur général de
la commission qui l'abordent c'est la
question de la fraude à l'assurance
maladie
je parle de la fraude à l'assurance
maladie par la fraude sociale
vous avez en septembre dernier remis un
rapport sur ces questions et qui avait
passé enfin qui n'a pas forcément été
repris et qui quand même représente une
somme estimée autour de 230 millions
d'euros
ce sont essentiellement les actes
médicaux sur côté ou mal côté les actes
médicaux et paramédicaux 1
les séjours dans les établissements les
prestations fictives les surfacturations
bref il semblerait qu'il y ait assez peu
de contrôle ou en tout cas que le
contrôle soit effectué sur un
échantillon ils n'ont pas sur
représentation comme ça l'est par
exemple dans le champ social autour de
la caisse d'allocations familiales qui
je le rappelle faire régulièrement et de
manière importante puisqu'il s'agit d'un
allocataire sur 20
ces contrôles au fil de l'année donc je
voulais savoir monsieur le premier
président si vous aviez l'intention de
poursuivre et de quelle manière
sur cette notion donc indispensable de
contrôler dans l'intérêt public de
chacun merci donc monsieur le premier
président la parole est à vous
merci je laisserais peut-être prise dans
mort à répondre aux questions très
précises
madame jasse ma fille j'ai commencé par
répondre à celle de la sénatrice
laurence cohen qui pose cette question
politique tout à fait décisive que nous
nous appartient pas de te répondre
encore une fois nous sommes à notre
place nous sommes pas ni le l'exécutif
ni le législatif mais tout de même ce
qu'il faut noter c'est qu'on effeuille
je crois qu'il faut partir des besoins
ça c'est clair ça paraît absolument
légitime
la cour ne s'attarde pas sur le ségur de
la santé jugé elle est consciente qu'il
faut moderniser notre système de santé
conscient des insuffisances qui peuvent
se présenter ici ou là et qu'on
interprète pas notre rapport comme étant
encore une fois une incitation je ne
sais quelle taille sociale ou je ne sais
quel casse sociale une fois la crise
sanitaire retombée il ya des problèmes
structurels qui existait des besoins
satisfaits
il s'agit pas du tout de le nier après
une fois que nous avons dit ça notre
rôle à nous c'est bien d'inciter à ce
que ses besoins soient satisfaits oui
mais au meilleur coût car si nous ne le
faisons pas à un moment donné la dette
se vengera et la dette sera butoir au
financement des services publics à ce
moment là ne restera que le choix entre
un modèle américain modèle libéral qui
peut-être pas celui que vous préférez
spontanément ou bien une baisse du
panier de soins à travers tes
remboursement massif donc je pense qu'il
ya pas de contradiction entre satisfaire
les besoins et contrôler les coûts
observons qu'il ya sans doute des marges
comment le démontrer par le fait que le
poids des dépenses de santé
en france est supérieur à ce qui existe
dans d'autres pays européens
les économies des dernières années ont
plutôt cherché à maîtriser les coûts
notamment à travers les rentes de
situation je pense qu'il faut aller vers
des mesures extrêmement structurelles
qui encore une fois si on lit notre
rapport vise à préserver la qualité de
soins à renforcer la solidarité et à
mieux gérer des organismes de sécurité
sociale ce sont des pistes qui sont à
creuser qu'on doit pas de manière
contradictoire au besoin enfin vous avez
évoqué la question des niches et des
exonérations ont dit plus shammam à 90
milliards on est à 100 me mignard et ça
effectivement
de la même façon que la question des
recettes a été soulignée par votre
collègue alain milon ce sont des sujets
qui sont tout à fait légitime pour ce
qui concerne les niches et les exos nous
pouvons contribuer à notre place évaluer
tout cela mais ensuite le débat va vers
pau vers les responsables politiques que
nous ne sommes pas où j'ai été que je ne
suis plus aujourd'hui mais bon s'il veut
résumer mon message c'est pas nier les
besoins c'est les satisfaire mais c'est
l'état tisseur au meilleur coût parce
que sinon un moment donné la dette
publique devient l'ennemi du service
public quand on est trop endetté le jour
où la charge d'intérêts s'alourdit à
nouveau
le jour où le crédit du pays s'affaiblit
à ce moment là un euro consacrée au
remboursement de la dette est un euro en
moins pour ce que nous avons à faire
pour l'hôpital mais aussi pour la
justice pour la sécurité pour
l'éducation pour tous les grandes
fonctions collectives auxquelles nos
concitoyens sont attachés il faut aussi
constater que la part socialisée de nos
dépenses de santé super à 75% que le
reste à charge pour les ménages 5% et
que c'est le plus faible d'europe donc
il n'y a pas que les ressources
budgétaires sur lequel on peut réfléchir
donc voyez je pense qu'il ya quelque
chose de plus globale la pensée notre
rapport et c'est normal parce que c'est
notre fonction s'attacher en effet le
retour à une maîtrise raisonnable de la
dépense il ya d'autres dimensions que
serions nous qui vous appartiennent ou
qui est la représentation nationale avec
un mouvement pour ce qui est de la
fraude à l'assurance maladie
en effet un rapport de septembre dernier
qui est bien situé 230 millions d'euros
la cnam n'évalue pas dans la base de la
cnaf
et pourtant il faut bien évaluer
contrôler et prévenir et sanctionner
donc ça sont des recommandations que la
cour fait pour ce qui concerne le
chapitre du ral ce pour ça que réseau
des urssaf
nous préconisons un élargissement des
lumières sion des urssaf qu'avec
l'absorption de la collecte agirc arrco
et ce que nous souhaitons c'est qu'on
continue à aller réseau social de
collecte unique
ça c'est une démarche qui est engagée
dont nous considérons n'est ce pas
monsieur le président bras qu'elle est
bonne et je vais peut-être vous laisser
enfin répondre aux questions de madame
victoire geste mal avec votre
autorisation madame la présidente sur
les on est des sujets de prévention
effectivement que madame jasmin a
souligné dans une de ces questions
comme l'a dit le premier président nous
travaillons beaucoup nous travaillerons
beaucoup sur ce sujet en 2021
puisque nous aurons fait 2-2
contributions importantes l'une sur la
prévention santé publique à la demande
du coc de l'assemblée nationale mais
nous sommes évidemment à disposition la
commission des affaires sociales du
sénat ainsi elle souhaite organiser
telle ou telle audition sur ce sur ce
sujet le deuxième sujet a déjà donné lui
un contact avec certains sénateurs
notamment monsieur bonne membres de
votre de votre commission
c'est le sujet de la prévention de la
dépendance sur lequel nous faisons qu
elle un sujet majeur sur lequel nous
faisons de également une évaluation de
politiques publiques pour ce qui sera
intéressant le moment venu de croiser
nos regards et je me tiens là aussi avec
les équipes de la sixième chambre
évidemment à disposition de la
commission pour toutes tout travail en
commun et toute audition que vous
pourriez souhaiter dans le courant de
l'année qui vient sur les la façon dont
les établissements hospitaliers peuvent
être soumis à des relations de
dépendance par rapport à tel ou tel
fournisseur j'ai un peu le sentiment
d'un que en répondant donc à cette
question également soulevé par la menace
matin un peu le sentiment que les
démarches qui ont été engagées notamment
à travers le programme phare qui est qui
se déploie depuis maintenant 7 8 ans
dans l'ensemble des établissements
hospitaliers de ce pays est aussi de
nature à mutualiser les achats et par
conséquent à leur permettre un permettre
aux établissements qui sont membres de
groupements ou de ou qui sont dans le
gaz et dans ses démarches de
mutualisation qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs
dans certains j'ai acheté de contourner
ces difficultés que vous soulignez à
juste titre et par conséquent d'obtenir
dans de très nombreux cas des conditions
financières beaucoup plus favorable je
voudrais rappeler que le programme fin
que j'évoquais à l'instant a permis de
dégager plus d'un milliard d'euros
d'économies et j'ai tendance à penser
que s'il ya des économies
concernant notre système de santé qui
peuvent être douloureuses je pense par
exemple à des économies touchant tel ou
tel des remboursements ou telle ou telle
ou telle hausse de ticket modérateur ou
telle ou telle franchise
al'inverse il est bien de pouvoir faire
de la productivité sur les achats grâce
à la mutualisation parce que c'est
autant de plus qu'on peut mettre sur la
prise en charge des patients et enfin
sur les la façon dont les systèmes
d'information en facilitent ou entrave
c'est la troisième question d'alain
jasmin le déploiement des dg acheter on
a effectivement observé qu'à très peu de
démarches de ce type au niveau des jeux
achetés et qu'on essaie il en a plutôt
le maintien
le système d'information qui parle
relativement peu entre adossé à chacun
des établissements hospitaliers membres
du g acheter d'un sujet qui d'ailleurs
est compliqué sur lequel je crois juste
titre il est prévu dans les prochaines
années dans les 6 milliards d'euros
d'investissements un effort particulier
sur le numérique en santé et sur les
systèmes d'information à l'hôpital qui
sont quand même très grand pas c'est
depuis très peu coussin même de l'ap-hp
qui est quand même le navire amiral d'un
système de santé tout tous patients
hospitalisés dans l'ensemble de l'ap-hp
quel que soit l'établissement dans
lequel il est hospitalisé à un numéro
d'identification unique
auparavant quand ils passaient d'un
établissement à l'autre jusqu'à il ya
peu il fallait refaire toute la démarche
est tout l'immatriculation du patient ce
qui est évidemment beaucoup plus
compliqué donc il ya des enjeux qui sont
très lourds sur lequel hôpital à
l'évidence très en retard et qui
pourront bénéficier de moyens
complémentaires dans le cadre des
programmes annoncés par le par le
gouvernement merci beaucoup à ma
précédente
merci beaucoup donc merci monsieur le
premier président est monsieur président
de la 6ème chambre pour pour ces
échanges de ce matin ils m'ont
simplement une petite formalité c'est de
demander à la commission l'autorisation
de publier l'enquète de la cour sur déjà
acheté qui sera précédé d'un avant
propos d'un à milon rapporteur
s'il n'y a pas de position il en est à 6
décidé je vous remercie et je laisse
passer un ces bons appuis voilà pour
cette audition de pierre moscovici le
président de la cour des comptes a été
auditionné dans le cadre de la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
un texte qui sera examiné au sénat à
partir de début novembre on en reparlera
bien évidemment sur public sénat rester
avec nous la formation politique et
parlementaire continue sur notre antenne